hi and welcome to this seventh lecture
in this course on reinforcement learning
my name is hadofan hustles and today i
will be talking to you about function
approximation and reinforcement learning
in terms of background material um
chapters nine and ten from saturn
embargo i are highly recommended and
we'll cover some material that's
captured in chapter 11 as well
and in terms of context we are always
considering this interaction loop where
there's an agent interacting with the
environment by picking actions and
observing the environment and then
reinforcement learning can be considered
the science of learning how to make
those decisions how can these agents
deal with this interaction stream and
somehow big actions that give it larger
and larger rewards the rewards not
depicted in the figure could be inside
the agent's head or they could be part
of the observation depending on how you
want to model your problem
inside the agent in any case there will
be some sort of a policy that determines
the actions and in addition the agent
might have value functions or
potentially models as well
the general problem involves taking the
kind into account time and consequences
because the action influences the
immediate reward but also potentially
the agent's state and also potentially
the environment state which means that
certain actions might have very
long-term consequences in addition these
consequences might not be immediately
obvious for instance an action might
change some internal state variable in
the environment and it might not be
immediately observable what that means
or what that matters but it might
influence later observations or rewards
now in this lecture we're going to talk
about function approximation and first
we're going to talk about why we need
that
so first we're just simply pointing out
in some sense that the policy the value
function the model and the agent said
update and all of these things that are
inside the agent can be viewed as being
functions for instance a policy maps the
agent's state to an action or to a
stochastic policy from which you can
sample an action a value function maps a
state to
a value which is an estimate of the
cumulative reward into the future the
agent state update itself maps the
previous agent state and the observation
into some new agent state
so these are all functions and we want
to learn these from experience why do we
want to do that well multiple reasons
one of which is flexibility as we talked
about in the very first lecture i quoted
a paragraph from a paper by alan turing
there where he argues that maybe it's
easier to program something akin to the
mind of a child than it is to program
something into the mind of an adult
because maybe it's actually easier and
also maybe better actually more flexible
to write something that can learn from
experience then try to list all of the
rules you may have learned from
experience
in addition if there's too many states
we will need some sort of approximation
this is a separate
point because this is no longer just
about learning but this is really about
function approximation that this is
important
and when we use neural networks to
represent these functions then this
subfield is often called deep
reinforcement learning these days
that term is actually relatively novel
it's like seven to eight years old but
the combination of reinforcement
learning with neural networks is in some
sense a quite natural one and is
actually fairly old and was has been
suggested at least in the 70s already
so in this lecture
we'll concretely consider predictions so
value functions including some
value-based control so using these
predictions to come up with policies in
upcoming lectures we'll talk more about
off policy learning approximate dynamic
programming which is uh the term we use
to refer to this more generic like field
of study where we're not necessarily
sampling but we're just considering what
if you have approximations in your
dynamic programming algorithms this
could include sampling this could
include function approximation but it
could also be from other sources
potentially
and this will allow us to talk about
these updates in a theoretical sense and
analyze what they are doing
this will also be an upcoming lecture
we'll also talk about learning policies
directly so as i mentioned the policy
itself can be considered a function so
you could consider updating that
function with policy gradients we
briefly talked about those in lecture
two we'll come back to that in a later
lecture
and we'll talk about model based rl as
well
in this lecture we're focusing on
predictions because it's nice to be able
to focus on something when we talk about
this function approximation but a lot of
the insights they do transfer to these
other cases as well as we will see
and in terms of motivation well why do
we want to do that because we're
ambitious we want to solve real problems
we want to solve large problems and
actually even small problems are large
problems because the game of backgammon
one could argue is not particularly
large compared to the real world it's
just a game but turns out that gammon
already has 10 to the 20th different
possible states so if you try to
enumerate all of those in a large table
in memory you quickly run out of space
if you try to do that for these type of
problems because if we then go to a
different game like the game of go we
notice that this actually already has 10
to 170
states that's an enormous number you
can't
feasibly store that in memory in a
computer and then try to learn a value
function for each of these separate
states
actually it can even get worse because
for instance let's consider helicopter
flying in which the stage spaces could
arguably taken to be continuous so you
could view the state space could for
instance be
the position of the helicopter in space
so there's this three-dimensional
space location
but in addition maybe there's other
inputs as well like the there might be a
wind sensor that tells you from which
direction the wind is blowing and how
fast it is blowing
and these inputs could all be real
valued numbers which means that the save
space is inherently continuous which
means that if you would like to
enumerate them there are infinitely many
states
and of course maybe as the ultimate
example you could think of a robot in
the real world where the environment is
actually equally big as the real world
is and in that case it's obviously
impossible to enumerate all of the
states because any computer that would
have to do that would have to live in
the real world and hence should be
necessarily much much smaller than the
world is so this is a common thing that
we have in mind when we think about
reinforcement learning we want
algorithms that can be applied to the
setting where this environment is just
humongously large and the agent must be
necessarily a lot smaller so the mind of
the agent including
its memory capacity must be necessarily
smaller than the environment
there are of course small problems small
leash problems in which you could still
enumerate all of the states and in that
case maybe you could try just doing
doing tabular approaches but in general
we want these algorithms to also apply
to these larger problems
so this is our motivation for why we
want to consider function approximation
and the intent is of course to apply the
methods that we've already been talking
about for prediction and for control
so let's talk a little bit about a value
function approximation now
so far we've mostly considered lookup
tables although i've already mentioned
linear function approximation and other
things in earlier lectures
but in the tabular case each state has a
separate entry and we just update that
or each state action pair has a separate
entry
but the problems with that is that there
are too many states as i mentioned
before so you cannot fit that in memory
that turns out it's not the only problem
a different problem is also too slow to
learn the value of each state
individually
so think of it this way so if you have a
problem that is not too large let's say
there's a million different states we
can store a million numbers in modern
computers that's not a problem at all
but then still if you would update each
of these state values individually and
separately then it would take quite a
bit of experience to learn reasonable
value estimates for each of these states
and indeed this feels inefficient if
these states have some commonalities
which we would then completely be
ignoring so if these states can instead
be viewed as being similar to each other
then maybe you would expect or maybe you
would want
the value of a certain state to be
updated when the value of a very similar
state
is updated this is called generalization
in addition to those two points
individual environment states are often
not fully observable so the environment
might not just be big it might also not
be fully observable from your
observation stream so we need to somehow
infer what
what's going on in some sense or at
least up to the point where we can make
meaningful meaningful predictions or
pick meaningful actions
so our solution for all of these
problems essentially will be to
introduce function approximation
for now we're just considering the
predictions as mentioned at the
beginning we're going to consider value
prediction in this lecture
and what that means is we're going to
introduce some parameter vector w as
before
where now the value function is
parametrized with this w
it's a functional state somehow where
the state is the agent state and we're
either approximating the value of a
certain policy or maybe of the optimal
value function
and the algorithms we'll get to in a
moment but the idea is that we're going
to approximate these
and then update the parameter for
instance using monte carlo algorithms or
td learning or any other similar
algorithm that you might want to use
and then hopefully if we pick our
function class correctly and we'll talk
about that more we will be able to
generalize to unseen states
so
in any case if you have such a function
the values of these unseen states will
be well defined you could of course also
have this for a table you could just if
you know all the states that you could
possibly end up in you could at least
initialize the values to be for instance
zero arbitrarily
but if you just have a function class
that automatically maps every possible
inputs to a valid outputs then you
automatically have this mapping and you
have a valid state estimate for every
state
in addition um i just want to briefly
talk about the asian states but i'll
actually not go into a lot of depth in
this lecture i'm just going to mention
it because it's very very important but
we'll get back to that in a subsequent
lecture
so i mentioned that the one of the
problems might be that the environment
say is not fully observable so
essentially the environment state is not
equal to the observation
then
as always we're going to rely actually
on the agent state instead and we're
going to sort of the agent set update
function here briefly which we could
also consider to be a parameter
parametric function of its inputs which
are the previous agent states the action
and the observation and potentially the
reward as well if that's not part of the
observation
and it has some parameters here denoted
omega
now we already discussed you could pick
this to be something you could pick this
just to be for instance the observation
the agent states at which point the
omega is maybe not relevant maybe there
are no parameters for that function
but maybe in general that's not very
particularly useful right if you look at
just the observation you might not see
everything that you need to see
so this agent states which we here
denote with a vector notation but we
will continue to use the random variable
notation as well
should contain everything that's useful
for you to make value predictions or to
pick your policy
and that means that the agent update
function is actually quite important and
might need to capture things like memory
for instance it might be that you have
to remember what you've seen before we
talked about an example in the first
lecture where maybe a robot has a camera
can only look in front of itself can't
see what's behind it but maybe it needs
to remember what is behind it to pick
suitable actions this would be captured
in the agent state and maybe we should
think about learning that in this
lecture we won't go into that but i just
wanted to remark it also to be clear
that in the subsequent slides whenever i
have a state it's always going to be the
asian state and this is basically just
going to be some vector
or the observation
okay now we're going to talk about a
couple of different function classes in
some a little bit more detail
just to talk about the differences
between them
so we started by talking about the
tabular case right where we just have a
table so our function class here is
tabular
and
then one step up from that would be
state aggregation so in a table we have
an entry for every single state for
instance let's consider for simplicity
that is fully observable so you
literally observe the environment state
and you just have an entry for every
environment state
in state aggregation you would instead
have an entry that
merges the values of a couple of states
so basically we just partition the state
space into some discrete small set
potentially
so that we can maybe learn the values of
these partitions instead of learning
them for every individual state and then
indeed we would get some generalization
because all of the states in the same
partition would then be updated with the
same algorithm and hence would obtain
the same value so if you reach a new
state in a certain partition that you
haven't seen before then it would
automatically already have a value and
it might be a suitable pattern
now one step up from this will be linear
function approximation and i want to for
now consider a fixed
agent state update function
and then a fixed feature map on top of
that
so this is why
why things will be linear because we're
going to assume that the agent set
update function for instance because you
speak the observation or do some other
fixed function there doesn't have any
parameters the feature map doesn't have
any parameters and instead all that
we're going to learn are the parameters
of the value function which uses those
features as input
so there is student agent update
function it might be a simple one but
we're just going to ignore that in terms
of the learning process
now note that state aggregation and
tabular are actually special cases of
this more general class because in the
tabular case we could just consider the
feature vector to have as many entries
as there are states and then have
the entry of these current states
would be one whenever you're in that
state and all of the other entries would
be zero so it's a one volt
representation as they sometimes call
this where the state is kind of picked
out by the feature vector
now state aggregation is very similar
except that the the size of the feature
map is no longer necessarily the same
size as the number of states so n what
we call that here on the slide the
number of outputs of this feature
mapping so the number of features in
your feature mapping
would not be equal to the number of
states would typically be much much
smaller and you could indeed even apply
this to continuous state spaces
but then it would still be a one-hot
representation when we do state
aggregation so there's some mapping that
says oh if you're in this states then
this entry must be one and everything
else must be zero um and if you're in
similar states maybe the same entry will
be one and everything else will be zero
but if you're in a different state then
a difference further away for instance
right then a different entry would be
one so it's still a one note
representation but it's a smaller
feature vector than uh if you would do
the fully tabular approach
and both of those are special cases you
don't need to have a onenote feature
representation you could consider much
richer function classes here
now one step up from that if we're going
to be even more flexible would be to
consider differentiable function
approximation
in this case our value function will be
a differential function of our
parameters w and it could be nonlinear
for instance it could be a convolutional
neural network that takes pixels as
input
you don't need to know right now what a
convolutional neural network is if you
don't know what that is it's just some
nonlinear function and one way to
interpret this is that you can consider
the feature mapping now no longer to be
fixed so we take whatever the agent
status as input and for instance the
input could just be the observations
could be the pixels on the screen when
we're say playing an atari game or
something like that and then instead of
having a fixed feature mapping you could
consider this to be a learned feature
mapping where something maps it into
features and then there's an additional
parameter on top of that that maps it
into values
in the notation we're going to merge all
of those features into one big vector w
but it won't be a linear function it
will be some nonlinear function where
these parameters are used in different
ways
so what we're requiring here why we call
this differential function approximation
is that we can still compute gradients
because we're going to consider gradient
based algorithms that's not a strict
requirement but it is one that we're
going to use here and it allows for very
rich function classes such as deep
neural networks
okay
in principle any of these can be used
but it's good to acknowledge that
reinforcement learning does have certain
specific properties or maybe often has
certain specific properties which might
interact with the function class so it's
good to be aware of those
the first one that i'm going to mention
is that the experience is not identical
and independently distributed with which
i mean that if you're going to learn
online from a stream of experience it's
just coming at you then successive time
steps are actually correlated
this is
not necessarily a problem i'm not saying
it because it's necessarily a problem
but i'm saying it because it's slightly
different from the case in which many of
these functions have been developed for
instance deep neural networks were
originally often developed and tuned in
cases of classification
for instance amnesty digit
classification
and then some choices that were made
there might not be completely
appropriate for reinforcement learning
because we're breaking some of the
assumptions such as that we can sample
each of these
learning examples independently
in addition to this the agent's policy
affects the data it receives what i mean
with this is that the reinforcement is
an active problem
and this has multiple consequences
including that actually one benefit of
this is that you can maybe actively
sample data in a way that is useful for
learning your function you could
literally have an expiration technique
that maybe seeks out certain parts of
the state space in order to improve your
value estimate specifically over there
you can't actually it's not active
learning you can't just sample any
sample that would be uh
within the field of active learning
that's the typical assumption that you
have a database and you want to
um indeed actively pick which samples
but you can pick from all of them that's
not typically the case in reinforcement
learning because the way we're
interacting with the world so if you
want to sample a certain situation you
actually first have to go there but it
is an active process and that's
interesting
but it also causes some issues for
instance the regression targets are
often non-stationary this is for
instance because we're doing control
like we might be changing our policies
as we go and this might not just change
the targets for our regression our value
targets for instance if we bootstrap but
it might also change the data so it's
actually non-stationary in more than one
way
in addition like i said the
bootstrapping is important
so even if the policy is fixed so even
if your policy is not changing the
targets might change because your value
estimates that you're using to construct
your targets could be changing so in td
we're using our value estimates and
those initially are not very good but
later they might become more accurate
in addition to this the world itself
might be non-stationary for instance
there might be other learning agents in
the world and maybe we also want to deal
with those cases and similarly but
differently the world might just be very
very large
so this might mean that you're never
actually quite in the same state
and these last two points actually quite
closely related because if we allow for
the world to be partially observable
then if the world is
sufficiently large it might appear
non-stationary to you because you might
think oh i'm going to that room i'm
going somewhere else and going back to
that room
things have slightly changed maybe the
sun is now setting whether it wasn't
setting before or maybe all of a sudden
there's a different agent in the same
room
and this is not
maybe literally non-stationary maybe the
actual underlying say physics of the
world are not changing but you don't
know all the the the latent variables
that are in the environment states that
make these things change so in some
sense non-stationary and
very large are in some sense similar but
of course they have different
connotations you could have a very tiny
non-stationary problem as well
so which function approximation should
you choose we covered a couple of
function classes
well it kind of depends on your goals
and one distinction to make is that for
for instance the tabular case we have
really good theory we understand these
algorithms really well we know when they
converge we know where they converge
they're quite stable the assumptions for
converges are not very strict so you can
fairly easily apply them and be pretty
certain that they will learn something
in addition i didn't put this on the
slide but they actually also tend to
learn relatively well and fast if the
state space is small enough
but they don't generalize they don't
scale you can't apply them to very large
problems as discussed
now in the linear case we're already a
little bit more flexible on our function
class we still have reasonable boost
theory so we understand these methods
quite well we know when they converge
and where they converge in many cases
but of course we are dependent on this
fixed feature mapping so we do require
very good features
now this is a bit of a subtle point
because the people are like people are
still debating this in some sense
because there's multiple aspects to this
one is that of course you're going to be
limited by the features that you have
and maybe that would be
a good reason to learn these features i
i most people these days are in that
camp
but you could also argue that maybe it's
okay to have somewhat poor features as
long as you have sufficient of them so
the other alternative would be to have
linear function approximation but with a
very very rich set of features and then
maybe you still have
a good enough set of features that you
can pick out the ones that you really
can use in the context that you require
them
and then of course there's nonlinear
function approximation which is less
well understood but it scales really
well and it tends to work quite well in
practice until it doesn't and then
sometimes we don't really understand
what's going on in some edgy cases but
of course our experience with this and
our understanding of this has been
growing quite a lot over the recent
years
and it's really flexible
and importantly it's it's much less
reliant on picking good features by hand
and i personally find this to be a very
convincing point and a very good point
because one thing that this means is
that you can apply these methods to
problems that you don't really
understand that well
but as long as you have a well
formulated reward function that you are
certain is the right reward function you
could apply these reinforcement methods
and then still get better
find good policies for these
domains without really needing to
understand what appropriate features
would be
and in fact we see more often
these days
over and over not just in reinforcement
learning but also in deep learning and
related fields
when applied these algorithms that don't
try to hand engineer features but
instead try to learn them from data
tend to outperform methods in which
these features are hand engineered
so that's interesting and it relates
again back to that point that insuring
was also trying to make
so deep neural networks are typically
used in this last category of non-linear
function approximations and in some
sense depending on how you define these
things some people would argue that
maybe any nonlinear function could be
argued is in some sense some sort of a
neural network it might be a weird one
another very strangely structured one
but in some sense these are somewhat
similar
so sometimes neural networks are used
almost synonymously with nonlinear
function approximation and these tend to
perform very very well in practice and
therefore remain a very popular choice
and there's also lots of research of
course happening trying to understand
these methods
better okay now this brings us to our uh
next topic where we're going to talk
about gradient based ref well be
creating based algorithms first a little
bit in general
so we're going to talk a little bit just
a very brief primer on gradient descent
and so basically descent um
and we're going to talk about this
because because of course we're going to
use that for value learning in a moment
so for now let's consider some arbitrary
function j this is just some function
only of the parameters right there's no
state input there's just parameters as
input
and we're going to consider it's
gradients just as a reminder a gradient
is a vector and it contains as its
elements each of the partial derivatives
for this function j with respect to that
one parameter out of w so ga here is a
scalar function with which i mean that
the parameter vector can be large but
the output is just a number
and we're good considering the gradient
of that
that function j with respect to the
parameters which we of course should
evaluate at certain parameters right the
gradient depends on where w is at this
moment
and the goal could then be to minimize j
so one way to do that is to move our
parameters w in the direction of the
negative gradients
and one way to do that would be the
algorithm
on the slide there's actually different
ways to do that as well
that are similar but slightly different
differences how they pick the step size
or exactly how they move or the
direction they move but a lot of the
algorithms derive essentially from this
main algorithm which is the gradient
descent algorithm where we have some
step size parameter and we just move
slightly in the direction of the
negative gradient
the one half here is optional maybe i
should get rid of that this is kind of
assuming that there's a square lost that
j is some sort of a square and that
therefore the the the one half will
cancel out with that
so the step size parameter should be in
some sense small
because then if we take a small enough
step we're in some sense certain that
we're going to decay as long as this
function j is smooth enough so you what
what i mean with smooth is that the
function counts have a very
big discontinuity
so if you know your function is somewhat
smooth then you know if your step is
small enough that the gradient will have
pointed in the right direction and
indeed it will go down
now of course in practice there's a bit
of a trade-off happening here because
you don't want to make alpha too small
because then learning is very small so
instead you typically tune this to get
good performance
now if we plug in value functions so
here we have the square loss that i
promised for instance we could consider
this one where we are simply interested
in this one number right again j doesn't
take serious input it's just a number
that depends on your parameters w and
the way it depends on that here we
define it to be the expectation over
some distribution of states for instance
due to your policy and of course the mdp
dynamics and we want to consider the
square difference between the actual
true value of your policy so we're doing
prediction in this slide and our current
estimate and that's something that we
might want to minimize right this will
be a predictive loss
and then we can just consider this
gradient descent algorithm here the one
half comes in handy because it cancels
out with the two that comes from taking
the derivative of the square
we note that the distribution in this
case does not actually depend on our
parameters so we can just push this
gradient into the expectation
and then we get this algorithm this
update if you will where the update to
the weights delta w would be small step
size alpha times the expectation under
that distribution over states
of the target which is our true value
function for for that state
minus our current prediction times the
gradient of that current prediction
this is an expectation so we can't
actually typically use that until unless
we really have the distribution over
states but if we want to use this in
practice we can sample this and that
means that we're going to sample the
state we're in and we're also going to
sample this
true value of the policy and one way to
do that would be to plug in the monte
carlo return which is indeed an unbiased
estimate for the true value of the
policy so this update this stochastic
gradient descent update on the slide
here is an unbiased estimate of the
gradient descent algorithm one line
above it
and that means if we take our step size
to be small enough and we take enough of
these steps that we will
on average move in the direction of the
gradients and we will also
reach the same basically
conclusions we reach the same solutions
as
as the great as the full gradient
algorithm would
so in that sense the caster gradient
descent is fine and it's just another
reason to pick a small step size so not
just because then the gradient is valid
but now also to average out the noise in
our estimate of the gradient
so we are often a little bit sloppy with
notation um this is just kind of a
warning for that so whenever we drop
terms so let's say we for instance write
the gradient of v and we don't have w's
anywhere and we don't specify where
we're taking this uh then typically we
mean when we have a gradient we mean
with respect to the parameters so we
have gradient of v just means with
whatever the parameters of v are so if
those are w then this would mean the
gradient with respect to w
and then we're also typically taking
that at whatever the current value of
these parameters are
so this is something that you'd actually
have to be explicit about the gradient
itself outputs in some sense a function
and you still don't have to plug in the
parameters where you're evaluating that
gradient and this is typically done in
notation with this bar where the
subscript tells you where we're
evaluating the gradient but people are
often very sloppy with the notation in
this and there's lots of shorthands for
instance people might might write
instead the gradient with respect to wt
of the value function of wt instead of
having this bar notation and that's fine
as long as from context is clear what
we're talking about so i just wanted to
highlight that here so that you have a
feel for oh if there's something that
gets dropped from a notation how should
we interpret it
it should be clear from context
okay and now we're going to go and talk
a little bit more in depth about linear
function approximation which is going to
be useful to understand the algorithms
and also some of the limitations of the
algorithms
so we talked about this previously but
i'm just going to reiterate a couple of
things that we said before we're going
to represent the state by some feature
vector where the state
sorry this feature mapping x is going to
be considered fixed
so
we have n elements here and different
features these are just numbers and
they're functions of state
and it might for instance take the
observations as input or more generally
your agent states and outputs some
feature vector of a certain size
and we also introduced some shorthand
where if we apply this function to state
at st so at time t we can also just
write x t and we can kind of pretend
that these are just our observations as
far as the algorithm is concerned the
algorithm only gets access to xt it
doesn't actually get access to st
anymore it just gets access access to
these features instead
so for example these features could
include distance of a robot from some
landmarks or it could be trends in the
stock market or it could be peas and
palm configurations in chess or whatever
you can come up with which might be
useful for the problem that you're
trying to solve
and i'll also show you an example where
you can somehow
find ways to kind of automatically pick
reasonable features for some some
problems
so this is that example um this is
called course coding and it's one way to
come up with a feature vector it's a
little bit related to that state
aggregation that we talked about before
but in this case we're not going to
actually subdivide the space into
disjoint chunks so what you see here in
the picture is that we've actually
subdivided a two-dimensional space
for instance you could think of this as
a location if you want to make it
concrete i didn't make it very concrete
here
and we're going to subdivide this space
but into overlapping regions and then
whenever we're in such a region so we're
here at this x say
and then we're going to have a feature
that is associated with each of these
circles
when you're in the circle the feature
will be one and whenever you're outside
of the circle it might be zero
if you do that with this representation
in this case three features will be
equal to one and all the other features
would be equal to zero so this is no
longer a one-half representation as we
discussed for the state aggregation or
the tabular cases in this case it would
be a few shot representation in some
sense the features are still binary are
either zero or they're one
but it's some sense already a richer
representation because as we can see
here from the figure
if you get these three
um
regions in some sense to light up we
actually know we must be in the
intersection of all three of them and
that can be useful information but in
addition to that we will still have some
generalization if we're going to update
the value associated with a state in
this very darkest region over here that
means that a different state say at y
will actually also be updated a little
bit because it shares one of the
features with this state that is going
to be updated so if we think of the
linear function that is going to be
applied to this it'll have a weight
associated with each of the features so
if we change the weight of that feature
that means that any position that shares
that feature where that feature is won
will also experience a slight change in
its value
now i described the binary case for
simplicity where you're either in a
region or you're out and your your
associated features either one or zero
but of course that's not the only option
you could instead also do something like
over here where you have some sort of a
distance function that might be for
instance gaussian
and instead of saying you're in you're
in a circle or you're out
we instead have a bunch of center points
of these circles and we just measure how
far you are from each and every one of
them which means that in this case for
instance we might have this feature
light up a little bit
uh well actually quite a bit because
we're a little bit closer to its center
and this one light up a little bit less
because we're further away from the
center maybe even the feature over here
still lights up very brief very very
lightly but very much less so than the
features much closer now of course you
would have to similar with the circles
you would have to consider how far do
you want your feature to be sensitive
but it would be provide a way to be a
little bit more continuous with your
value functions
whatever you do there basically the idea
is then you have your representation and
you expand this into a whole
bunch of different features and then you
can press that with your weights which
are here to know that theta
but you can think of this as being the
same as the w from the previous slide
into a single number
why do we say expand here well in this
case note that we had a two-dimensional
representation
we could have also maybe had
say an x-y location which would
constitute two two numbers and we could
have fed that to the agent but maybe
it's really hard for the agents to
turn those two numbers with a linear
function into a valid value estimate
right the only thing you can do then is
some sort of a linear
linear function over the state space you
can't have any non-linearity in terms of
your location and how the value reacts
to your location if you would only feed
in the actual location numbers the x y
coordinates
so what we're doing here instead is
we're turning those two numbers of this
two-dimensional space
into very many numbers as many as we've
defined these circles
so in some sense we're actually blowing
up the representation
in order to then be able to apply a
linear function to that this is a common
technique it's also used in for instance
support vector machines doesn't matter
if you don't know what those are but if
you do then you might recognize this
principle
where we're basically just blowing up
the feature space into something large
in the hope that then the feature
representation will be rich enough that
a linear function suffices that if you
then apply a linear function to these
features you still have a good enough
approximation
now it might immediately be obvious that
there are some limitations to this
approach or if not then maybe let me
point at some for instance it might be
quite hard so if you only have two
dimensions maybe you can define these
circles and you're good to go but what
if you have many many dimensions what if
you have 10 dimensions or maybe even 100
dimensions and this is not very
fictional because of course if we think
of locations in the world maybe we'll
think like two dimensions three
dimensions maybe that's enough but as i
mentioned for the helicopter example a
helicopter might not just be in a
location in three-dimensional space but
it might also have other sensors it
might have
some
audio sensors it might have wind sensors
it might have
other sorts of sensors it might be
measuring i don't know air pressure or
humidity
so these would all be dimensions and it
might actually be very hard to somehow
figure out a good subdivision of that
space without making the feature
representations
extremely large
this is sometimes called the curse of
dimensionality
which is actually termed due to richard
bellman also known from the bellman
equations
okay so this is just meant to be an
example of how you could somewhat
automatically construct these features
because you could imagine if you do have
a fairly small dimensional space like
two dimensions that you could just
sprinkle a couple of these circles in
there you maybe don't have to think very
carefully about where they are maybe you
don't need to understand the domain that
well for you to get a reasonable
function for a reasonable feature
representation
but of course there is a choice here and
here's a couple of examples so on the
left hand side in a
we see narrow generalization we've
picked these circles to be fairly
small and what this does is it allows
you to be quite specific so if the value
function is updated only in this region
that lights up and then maybe mostly
updated in the smallest region because
of your representation that means that
you have narrower generalization if you
update this state states fairly near to
it get updated as well but states
further along or not and that's both
good and bad this is a double edged
sword if you have narrower
generalization this means the narrower
it becomes the more specific your value
function can be
and the more precise it can be if you
need very like high resolution in some
sense in your value function because the
actual value function might for instance
be quite bumpy or weird then it might be
useful to have very narrow
generalization but it does mean that
learning might progress quite slowly
because there's very little leaking from
the state information from states
further away
so instead you could consider having
broad generalization where the the
overlap is much larger the circles are
much larger then updating just a state
in the middle would actually update a
fairly large region of your state space
and this can be useful
because it might speed up learning but
you lose out in terms of your maybe your
resolution at the limit when you've
learned your value function there's a
limit to how precise you can make it at
every situation
of course depending on your dimensions
here like we don't know what x and y are
here in terms of dimensions it could be
that you actually want to pick something
more custom that the best representation
would be asymmetric so this already
shows it alludes to the fact that it can
be quite tricky to pick these things in
general
the other thing i want to note is that
we're actually aggregating multiple
states and this means that the resulting
feature vector and hence
like what the agent observes in some
sense will be non-markovian
what i mean with that is that you're in
this little region here in the middle
and let's say the agent moves right but
it only moves a little bit
then you would end up in the same region
the same features would light up so from
time step to time step while you remain
in a small little region in the middle
the feature representation would not
change while you're moving within that
region
and then at some point you actually step
out of the region into the next one
now this is why that's
non-markovian because the time step at
which that happens as far as the agent
is concerned it can't tell right so
there's actually some probability
distribution happening here where the
underlying state of course there is a
certain moment which you actually
transition
let's say the let's say the effect of
the actions are deterministic so when
you move right you actually move right
so maybe there's like a true transition
which is completely deterministic but
the agent doesn't know when it happens
so what happens here instead is that as
far as the agent is concerned so at some
random point in time you'll transition
from one region to the other
this is the common case this
non-markovian is the common case when
using function approximation it's not
specific to this it's just very easy to
visualize in this representation but
whenever you use function approximation
including deep neural networks and so on
you should count on the fact that in
some sense as far as the algorithm is
concerned there might be some partial
observability
because the function approximation will
if it's a good function approximation it
will in some sense generalize things
so for the linear case specifically we
do want to consider when good solutions
even exist so it's good to kind of do
this mental check so if you have if
you're given a certain feature
representation or if you're considering
a certain feature representation if
you're picking it yourself it's good to
imagine well if i would have the best
possible weights what would it look like
is it good enough is my um
generalization say narrower enough that
i can have good enough resolution
or is it broad enough that i can have
fast enough learning so it's good to
just think that through for your future
representation and then sometimes you
might catch things so oh there's no way
you could learn this value function
because it simply cannot be distinguish
between these two different important
states for instance
neural networks tend to be much more
flexible in that sense so if you just
give pixels to the neural network it
could itself figure out how to maybe
subdivide the space in some sense right
and come up with some sort of internal
feature mapping
um that is maybe more suitable to the
actual problem that you're trying to
solve because you could imagine that if
you want to make these feature mappings
flexible if you could make them flexible
that this could be a lot stronger where
maybe you have asymmetric generalization
in some part of the state space broader
generalization in another part and very
narrow generalization in some parts
where it's really important to get the
values right a neural network can in
some sense automatically find that
okay now we're going to move on to
linear model-free prediction
so we're going to talk about how to
approximate the value function with a
linear function approximation we talked
about this before but just to be very
explicit
we're going to approximate the value
function by having this parameter vector
w multiply with this feature vector x
which we can write out very explicitly
by just having a summation over all of
the components of both of these vectors
that's just a dot product
and then we could define our objective
to be as before a quadratic objective
where we compare to the true value v pi
for now let's just assume that we have
that true value and we'll go we'll plug
in real algorithms in a moment but for
now we just consider that we have those
regression targets and there's going to
be some distribution over states
this distribution is called d here and
for instance it could be due to your
policy or maybe you have some different
way to sample the states
then this algorithm can converge to the
global optimum if we do stochastic
gradient descent
um if we would regress towards this true
value function
even if we use a stochastic update where
the stochasticity here comes from
picking the value function so you see
the update here and the update rule in
this case is somewhat simple because
in the linear case the gradient of our
value function will simply be our
feature vector
so that means that our update to the
waves our stochastic gradient descent
update will be step size times
prediction error the true value minus
our current prediction where the true
value is v pi and our current prediction
is vw times the feature vector the
feature vector here is just the gradient
of your value function in the linear
case those are the same
now we can't obviously update towards
the true value function if we don't have
that yet
so instead we're going to substitute the
targets this is similar to what we
talked about before when we talked about
prediction and for instance for monte
carlo we could plug in the monte carlo
return but of course we could also do
temporal difference learning and then we
could plug in the temporal difference
target which is just
in the one step case it's just the
immediate reward plus the discounted
value at the next state
so this is now a placeholder for the
true value of this state and we can use
that to have
data dependent updates where we don't
have any hidden information anymore we
don't have any privileged information
about the true value of
of the state
of course we can also go in between
these with tdt tdtd labda as discussed
before where g lambda is a louder return
which bootstraps a little bit on every
step and continues a little bit on every
step and then this lab that trades off
between these two algorithms td and
monte carlo as mentioned earlier we're
not going to go into there now but
in an earlier lecture we then turned
this into editability traces where we
could still have a
causal algorithm that can every step can
update rather than having to wait all
the way until the end of the episode so
this is just a reminder that td labla
can be implemented
to not have to wait all the way into the
end of the episode and in fact so can
monte carlo
now return is an unbiased sample of the
true value
and therefore we can kind of view this
as supervised learning where we just
have a data set of states and returns
and then the linear monte carlo policy
evaluation algorithm which uses that
return but then instead of the gradient
has its feature vector will converge to
the global optima this is known because
[Music]
we're basically trying to find the
minimum of a quadratic function which is
convex and then stochastic gradient
descent with an appropriately decaying
step size we'll find the optimal
solution
so that's nice under some mild
assumptions one of the assumptions is
that we sample iid but it turns out we
can relax that assumption and it will
also find the right solution if you
don't sample fully iid as long again as
your
as your step size decays sufficiently
and of course there's some other
conditions as well just to mention one
of those you can only find the global
solution of course if your data supports
that so one thing that you need for
instance is that you can never make an
irreversible decision right if there's
just one state where you make a decision
you can never go back that means that
the information before going into that
state won't have been visited infinitely
often which means that convergence then
for those states at least is off the
table this is an assumption that's often
called ergodicity
there are similar other named
assumptions as well but it basically
means that your mdp is connected in the
sense that you can always eventually at
least return to states you visited
before
so this actually converges also when
using nonlinear value function
approximation although then it can
convert to a local what we mean here is
that if you have a non-linear value
function your lost landscape
might have multiple hills and valleys
stochastic gradient descent on that lost
landscape is still
guaranteed to go down but it's a local
algorithm so it could go down into some
valley gets stuck there even though
there's a lower value so a way to have
lower loss somewhere else but it's still
nice to have that convergence because it
turns out we can't always guarantee a
convergence and sometimes you might have
parameters that diverge that go to
infinity for instance we'll see an
example of that later in this
lecture so of course we can also
consider td learning we know that the
target here is a biased sample of the
true value but we can apply the same
trick where we consider this to kind of
be training data where we have states
and we have the associated targets for
those states and we could update towards
those in a very similar way so this is
very similar to monte carlo this is
basically just doing a regression in
some sense
but using the td error rather than the
monte carlo
so this now is again to a non-stationary
regression problem
because we're using the value function
itself to construct the targets that's
good to note that there's something that
is different here from the monte carlo
case
and the target depends specifically on
our parameter so it's not just even just
any non-stationary regression problem
it's one where we're actually updating
the parameters ourselves and that makes
the targets more stationary and that's
something to keep in mind because this
turns out to be important for the
stability thief of these algorithms
so now we're going to very briefly touch
upon control with value function
approximation this will be relatively
straightforward because we've talked
about these things before
so just as a recap we're going to do
some version of policy iteration in some
sense and policy iteration depends on
two steps one is policy evaluation and
the other one is policy improvement to
start with the latter for policy
improvement we consider something fairly
simple so if we estimate action value
functions we can just use epsilon greedy
policy improvement or
greedy pulse improvement but then you
wouldn't explore sufficiently
but
we can just consider something fairly
simple there but then the approximation
step is the difficult one if your state
space is really large and there are
therefore we're going to plug in value
functions approximation for that step
so we're basically just going to
approximate the value function for the
state action pairs in a very similar way
as before
and if we use a linear function we could
for instance define our feature vectors
now as dependent not just on state but
also on action and then they have the
shared parameter vector w which is
applied to this feature vector and then
gives you the suitable value
estimate the update is as before this is
extremely uh
similar to what we had before except
that everything now depends on states
and actions rather than just states
and
in the linear case it turns out there's
actually multiple things we could be
doing
so a different way to approximate the
action value function
is as follows where
instead of defining a feature vector
that depends on state in action we could
have a feature vector that only depends
on state
now the action value function is now no
longer a scalar function which is why i
bolded it here
so this is the difference between the
previous slide let me go back to the
previous slide first here we're doing
the same thing as we were doing for
value fun functions for state value
functions
where we now have a feature vector that
depends on both state and action
and then the q value is just a number
right so we have our feature vector x
which is the same size as our parameters
w and the inner product will just give
you a number now we're going to do
something different where now we have a
feature matrix w
and we're going to multiply a feature
vector that only depends on state with
this feature matrix and the feature
matrix is shaped in such a way that the
output of this will have the same number
of elements as we have actions
a different way to write down the same
thing would be as follows where we still
have this scalar function for state and
action and it's going to be defined as
indexing this vector that we get from
this first operation with the action so
we have a matrix that has size number of
actions by number of features so when we
multiply that with the number of
features we get a vector of size number
of actions and then we just index in
there to get the action value for this
action that we're interested in
this can also be written as follows
where we basically have a separate
parameter functional per action
but we have a shared feature vector
so let me again go back
previously we had one shared parameter
for all actions and we had separate
features for each action
now we have one shared feature vector
and separate weights per action
this is a slight difference but it might
be important in some cases
the updates are very similar to before
so we can just update the parameters now
associated with just the action that
we're interested in and we can just not
update the parameters of all the actions
that we
are not interested in because they
correspond to different actions
so b here is just any action that's
different from the one that we're
updating a
and equivalently we can write this down
as follows where i here is an indicator
vector that indicates the action so it's
a one-hot vector that has as many
elements as there are actions
and then only the element corresponding
to the action that we've just selected
has a has a value of one and all of the
other elements has a value of zero and
then we take the outer product with the
state
features and this will give us the
update to our parameters
now this might look a little bit
complicated feel free to step through of
this fairly like much slower than i'm
doing right now
but i also before you do that it might
be good to recognize that actually a lot
of these things can be automated there's
a lot of software packages these days
that use auto differentiation that allow
you to
basically compute derivatives without
doing them by hand so i want to maybe
make you aware of the differences
between these methods because they are
different these different ways to
represent an action value function
but then in terms of computing these
updates we don't actually have to
manually compute these outer products
for instance by hand instead we can just
call
a gradient function from someone from
auto differentiation package and use
that
examples of those include tensorflow pi
torch and i like jax these days to do
that
okay
so
this raises a question should we use
action in where the action is part of
your feature representation or action
out where we just have a state dependent
feature representation and then just
compute all of the action values for all
of the different actions
so the action in approach is when your
feature vector depends on state in
action you have the shared weight vector
w the action out approaches when you
have a
weight matrix w and you have features
that only depend on state
one reuses the same weights across
actions the other one reuses the same
features or transactions it's unclear
which one is better in general but they
do have some certain other properties
for instance if we have continuous
actions it does seem easier to have an
action in approach because it's you
can't have an infinitely large matrix so
the action out approach seems much more
troublesome if you have continuous
actions
a different way you could deal with that
is to parameterize your policy
differently not have literally a
separate value for every action if you
have infinite actions that might be hard
you can do that by having an action in
network or
there are other ways you could do that
if you want to do something similar to
an actual outdoor network but we won't
go into that here i just wanted to to be
aware of these choices essentially
which are in some sense representation
choices now we're picking our function
class in a sense and even if we restrict
ourselves to a linear function class it
turns out there's already design design
decisions that you have to make and
these might matter for the performance
of these algorithms
for small discrete action spaces the
most common approach these days is
action out so for instance the dqn
algorithm which i'll come back to at the
end of this lecture that was used to
play these atari games did this approach
where there was a neural network a
confident in this case which would take
the pixels as input then go through a
couple of layers of convolutions and
then a couple of fully connected layers
if you don't know what those terms mean
that's okay but then in the end it would
output
a vector with the same number of
elements as there are actions in atari
there is up to 18 different actions so
this is a fairly manageable size so we
just output a vector of size 18 and the
semantics of this vector would be that
for each of the elements this would
correspond to the value of that specific
action
for continuous actions it's much more
common to have the action in approach
where the action is somehow
given as an input to the network so you
have to represent it of course somehow
so the network can easily use it but
then you can do that
okay now we talked of in the previous
lecture about sarsa as td applied to
state action pairs so it inherits the
same properties what we're doing now is
moving towards td algorithms right
um but it's easier to do policy
optimization with sources than this with
td because we have these action values
and therefore we can do policy iteration
so kind of obviously we might want to do
sarsa to learn these action values with
function approximation
and indeed you can do that for instance
for this small example here it was done
for this small example which is the game
of well it's not really a game sort of
like an example a benchmark of mountain
car
so what is it how does this work let me
explain
the cart here
starts at the bottom or somewhere maybe
randomly in this valley depending on
which version of this environment you
look into and the goal is to drive up
the hill and the hills to its right
there's only two actions or three
depending on the version of this uh
setting um and these actions correspond
to going full force in one direction
full force in the other direction or not
doing anything at all and this is
literally applying force so if you pick
to go right that doesn't mean that
you'll drive with a fixed velocity to
the right no it means you're applying a
certain acceleration to your car so
there's a momentum here to the card
and also of course if the card happens
to be driving downhill it will speed up
if it happens to be driving uphill it
will slow down it's a very simple
physics uh
simulation in some sense and then the
goal is to go up that mountain to the to
your right but turns out the car is not
strong enough to do that it's engine is
not strong enough so what the actual
optimal policy is is to go left first
then start driving down and use the
momentum from going down to then drive
up the other hill and this is sometimes
used because it's a somewhat tricky
exploration problem if you don't know
there's any goals to be had or any like
rewards to be attained that are non-zero
it could be quite hard for the car to
figure out it should leave this ravine
at the bottom
and what we see here now is um
a value function
after a number of episodes and we see
that the shape of that value function
changes over time as we add more uh
episodes
the interesting thing that i wanted you
to basically look at here is not just
the evolution of this value function but
also its shape at the end which is quite
special it's not a very simple value
function this is because
um it depends where you are if you're
far enough up the hill to the left then
the optimal value would be to go the
optimal choice would be to go down and
then up the other end but if you happen
to be slightly further down you're not
high up in the uh eye up the hill enough
yet
then it could be better to
um go up further and this also depends
on your velocity if you're here and you
have a certain velocity or let's pick
the down like the bottom part of the
valley if you're here and you happen to
have no velocity then you should be
going to the left because you should be
driving up this hill first and then down
and up the other but if you're here at
the bottom but you do have a velocity at
some point you have enough velocity that
your optimal policy switches from going
to the left to going to the right
straight to the goal
so you can see these discontinuities
kind of showing up in the shape of this
value function here where you can see
these ridges
and these are indeed the differences
between am i already going fast enough
that i should be going right and will i
then reach the goal very quickly or am i
too far away and should i be going to
the other end and eventually i'll get
there but my reward will be lower or my
values will be lower because of
discounting
so this is a discounted problem and this
is why you can see that the agent
basically wants to go as quickly as
possible alternatively
not it's not just because of discounting
you could also for instance give a
reward of minus one on every step and
you would see similar discontinuities as
well
so what was the representation here for
this mountain car
it's using tile coding and i'll briefly
explain what tile coding is without
going into too much detail
basically what was happening here is
there's these two inputs there's the
velocity of the agent let me go back to
this one and there's its position
and this was basically cut up into small
little tiles by discretizing them
now what tile coding does so the
simplest version of tile coding is just
state aggregation you just
cut up the whole space into little
squares and you're done like this is
this is your feature representation
alternatively you could also cut it up
into larger squares but then have
multiple of those overlapping this is
similar to what we talked about for
course coding where now instead of being
in one of these squares you could be in
multiple squares
at the same time
one such discretization of the sage
space we could call a tiling of the
state space and then tile coding could
apply multiple tilings that overlap
but they don't exactly overlap so
they're kind of offset from each other
so that you could be in
one tile
from one tiling but in a different tile
from a different tiling and if you move
slightly you transition from one to the
other tile in one of the tilings but not
in the other necessary this is very
similar to the circles we saw before for
course coding so it's basically the same
idea but with
squares rather than circles
and then if you have that you have some
sort of a feature mapping you can apply
a linear function approximation to this
and this was applying linear success to
that
and here's a plot showing the
[Music]
performance of the algorithm
where the y-axis is the steps per
episode so this is not your reward but
it's very related to the reward except
that lower is better
fewer steps per episode means you're
doing better so this is a measure of
performance where low is better and this
is averaged over the first 50 episodes
and then also over 100 runs to get rid
of some of the variance in the results
and we can see here an n-step approach
where there is an n of one or two or
three or well three is not there but
four or eight
and we can see something similar to what
we saw before
where depending on the step size
and the the uh the end step in your
return you get a slightly different
profile where larger ends tend to tend
to prefer smaller step sizes but then
for intermediate ends you you get the
best performance we saw this before for
pure prediction it turns out to also
work for control that these intermediate
values tend to work uh
well
especially if you're interested in a
limited amount of data note that the x
axis is actually our step size times the
number of tilings in this case eight
so this is a common thing because what
we often do if we do something like tile
coding
note that all of your features are
binary right they're either one or zero
because you're either in a tile or
you're not so the number of features
that are equal to one in your feature
representation is equal to the number of
tilings and then it turns out it's
convenient to
basically
pick your step size in such a way that
takes it into account because the
magnitude in some sense of your feature
vector now depends on the number of
tilings
this is more generally a useful thing to
keep in mind that the magnitude of the
features might matter and if you're just
doing the std algorithm you might
actually want to adapt your step size to
take it into account for instance if you
know the average magnitude of your
features maybe you want to somehow adapt
your step size to be lower if that
magnitude is higher or vice versa
alternatively a similar but opposite
approach would be to normalize the
feature vectors maybe you don't want to
do that on a case-by-case basis because
that might change the semantics of a
feature vector but you could have some
sort of a global normalization which
basically means that the average feature
vector for instance it has unit length
and that might make it easier to pick
your step size
if you don't do this maybe somewhat
obvious in hindsight if you just
consider the same algorithm but you
don't take into account the feature
vector then you could consider the exact
same algorithm but with different
features where the only difference
between the features is that there's
some constant scaling and then turns out
the performance is different if you
don't take it into account by picking
your step size
so that's like this little subtlety
that's good to be aware of
in practice what people often do is they
tune the step size to get good
performance
for instance by just running at a little
little bit of time or running it on some
similar problem if you're doing
something uh
where you need to do well immediately on
the real problem but often we do these
things in simulator so you can run this
multiple times and you could just find
out what good values are and then it's
very useful to plot these plots like we
have here which is called a parameter
study we're basically just not looking
at what's the best performance that i
could tune but we're actually looking at
how sensitive are these algorithms two
different step sizes n-step parameters
and so on
okay that concludes that example now
we're going to talk more generally a
little bit about conversions and
divergence of these algorithms
so when do these algorithms converge
what do we mean with convergence we mean
that they find a solution reliably that
they find some sort of a minimum of
something
so do they converse when you bootstrap
when you use function approximation when
you learn off policy and turns out it's
a little bit subtle it's not always the
case ideally we want algorithms that
converge in all of those cases
or alternatively we want to understand
when the algorithms converge and when
they do not so we can avoid cases where
they do not and we'll talk about this at
some length now
so let's start with the simplest case
which is the monte carlo setting
i talked about this already i mentioned
that this is a this is like a sound
algorithm it will converge so the monte
carlo algorithm if we're not considering
the stochastic case we're just going to
consider like the the loss there first
you can see there an eq
equation which has
an argument over something but let's
first focus on the on the thing inside
there there's an expectation over the
policy this is similar to what we had
before
instead of having a d there i now put pi
there to basically illustrate that the
distribution of states but also the
return depends on your policy in this
case
and then we consider this squared loss
which is our monte carlo
loss essentially and we want to find the
parameters that minimize the squared
error we're going to call that wmc w for
monte carlo
and i'm arguing here i'm basically just
stating that the solution to this will
be this equation there on the right
this is a linear
like this basically linearly square
solution so if you've seen that before
this would look very familiar and what
we see here that is essentially it's the
expectation of the outer product of your
features
and that expectation is then inverted
this is a matrix so this is an inverse
matrix times the expectation of the
return times your features and that
turns out to be the solution that monte
carlo finds
we can verify this so let's just step
through that
when when are we done like when is the
algorithm converge well it's a
gradient-based algorithm so we are
converged when the gradient is zero
because then or i should say if the
expected gradient is zero because we're
doing stochastic gradient descent
because if the expected gradient is zero
of our uh loss essentially the thing
that we're optimizing that means that in
expectation we're no longer changing the
parameter vector so when this is the
case this is then we have reached what
is called a fixed point
so we can just state okay well
we're going to be at some sort of a
fixed point let's assume that we don't
know what wnc is yet we're going to
derive that here so we're just going to
take the gradient with respect to those
parameters and we're going to say well
that's going to be equal to zero or at
the fixed point
so then we can just write that thing out
so first thing to do is to write out the
value estimate explicitly as this linear
function that it is
and then we're going to move things
around so first we're going to pull the
feature vector outside of the brackets
inside
we notice that this
inner product times a feature vector can
also be written by putting the feature
vector in front of this inner product
because this is just a number right so
we can basically move this one around
but then we can consider this to also be
kind of like an outer product times your
weight factor instead because the order
of uh products here doesn't matter right
we could put brackets around the inner
product here or we could bracket
brackets around the outer product here
that's the same thing
the otherwise the x just gets moved next
to the return
so we've just pulled that feature vector
inside the brackets that's all
then we rearrange and we basically know
that this expectation is just one
expectation minus a different
expectation so let's move the minus part
to the other side
and
then we see that this should be equal to
that when the gradient is zero now all
that's left to do is to take that
inverse of that matrix on the left hand
side which therefore is assumed to exist
otherwise this step is not valid
and then we get our solution
so when is that step valid well so
there's a distribution over states there
right and there's an inner sorry outer
product of feature vectors so when is
this typically valid it's typically
valid
if your
state space is large and your feature
vector is small that's like one case in
which it's valid because then
assuming at least that your features are
non-degenerate so you have different
features for different states
then if there's at least as many
different feature vectors that you can
encounter as there are numbers in your
feature vector as there are like
components in your feature vector then
this inner product typically exists
so this is
the common case essentially like
typically you will have many more states
and you will have features that do
change when you go to different states
and then this
sorry this outer product the expectation
of that will typically be invertible but
it is a technical assumption otherwise
uh you're not guaranteed to converge it
might actually still be that the
algorithm still converges but it might
not converge to a point it might instead
convert to a line or a plane if that's
if you can't invert that matrix it
depends a little bit on the technical
details
so the agent state here does not have to
be mark off this is fully defined in
terms of the data that's kind of
interesting right so we don't have to
have a markovian feature vector or
anything like that basically the fixed
point here is defined fully in terms of
the x t's it's not even defined in terms
of the agent state it's defined in terms
of the features that you observe
so that's kind of interesting we didn't
need that property
now we can maybe see if we can do the
same for td so let's consider the td
fixed point so i'm going to argue here
that this converges to this different
thing
look at it for a second and i'll go back
to the previous slide
so the monte carlo thing
was this outer product
the expectation thereof inverted times
the return times your feature
this looks quite a bit different
there's a different outer product here
this is still an outer product but
instead of being the other product of
the feature with itself
it's the other product of the feature
with itself minus the next feature
that matrix is inverted if it exists
under similar assumptions as i just
mentioned before it would exist
it typically exists but doesn't have to
and then times the reward times your
feature factor not the return but the
reward so this is a different fixed
point it doesn't just look different it
typically actually is different from the
monte carlo fixed point
so now we're going to verify again as we
did from the monte carlo case that this
is indeed the fixed point so we're going
to consider the td update and we're
going to assume that the expected update
is 0 where the expected update is given
as this
this is similar to what we're doing from
monte carlo so we're basically just
considering the update we're saying oh
what is this update zero
and then we're just going to manipulate
it in a similar way here we're again
going to pull in this feature vector
first
and we put it
next to the reward
on one end the step size here is
actually not that important though i'll
get rid of
rid of it in a moment so we're going to
put it next to the reward and we're also
going to put it next to these two scales
but we're going to put it on the left
hand side which we can just do because
these are just numbers
and then having put that on the left
hand side
we notice that on the right hand side we
have these wtd
so we can also pull that outside of the
brackets
which means we are left with this gamma
times
x t plus 1 minus x t both of which are
transposed because they were multiplying
with this weight vector
right
okay so now we can again rearrange
things so let's pull this thing to the
other side
so there's a plus here so to put it to
the other side it must become a minus
but we actually fold that minus inside
this little term over here so note that
the order has changed that's because
there used to be a minus in front and we
just pushed it inside and instead
flipped the order
in addition let's just pull out the
transpose here let's pull out the
transpose outside of the brackets so we
just first subtract one vector from the
other and then transpose it to come up
with this other product
and now finally we move this part to the
other side by multiplying with its
inverse again assuming that that exists
and we notice that because the
the learning rate is inside the
expectation and we're inverting for
simplicity for instance consider here a
constant step size just for argument's
sake but you can get rid of it in other
ways
we can see that this step size will
actually cancel out with that one
because
moving this one to the other side by
multiplying with the inverse kind of
means we're multiplying with one
over the step size which cancels out
with this step size so we get the fixed
fouring becomes this one
so this is kind of just verifying that
the fixed point is indeed the one that
is listed above and we have
like substantial proof these days that
this is indeed where td converges if it
converges it's important to note that
this differs from the monte carlo
solution and typically the monte carlo
solution is actually the one that you
want
why well because the monte carlo
solution is defined as minimizing that
thing that we actually want right this
is actually minimizing the difference
between the return
and the value this is sometimes called
the value error or the return error
and this is an unbiased the gradient of
this is unbiased with respect to the
using the true value instead of the
return as well but actually one could
also argue that we don't actually even
care about a true value we just care
about having a small error with respect
to the random returns that's also valid
so this seems to be exactly what we want
in some sense and then if td converts it
somewhere else this might be
undesirable in some sense and this i
think in general is quite true that
monte carlo typically converges to a
better value than temporal difference
earning does
when you start using function
approximation
however temporal difference learning
often converges faster
and of course we can trade off again we
can pick an intermediate labda or an
intermediate n and kind of get the best
of both worlds you could even consider
changing this over time you could start
with a small end and then slowly
increment it over time and in the end in
the limit maybe still come up with the
monte carlo solution if you draw if
you'd like
um
so there's a bit of a trade-off here by
it's variance trade-off again similar to
what we had before but now td is biased
asymptotically as well in the tabular
case this is not the case in the tabular
case both monte carlo and td find the
same solution but if we add function
approximation even just for linear
function approximation td remains biased
which means that it actually finds a
different solution in the limit
so it does converge if it converges to
this fixed point
and we can actually characterize it a
little bit farther by considering the
true value error
which is defined as this difference
between the true value and our current
estimate weighted according to this
distribution over states where here we
use d pi to denote that this
distribution depends on our policy
and then monte carlo actually minimizes
this value error completely but td
doesn't but we can say something about
where td what td reaches and we can say
that the true value error of td
is bounded in the following way where
it's small or equal to one divided by
one minus gamma times the value error of
monte carlo
which is equal to the minimum value area
that you can get
under any weights
so what is this saying well this is
basically saying that td is doing maybe
a little bit worse asymptotically than
monte carlo it's doing um
something different right it's biased
but we can bound how bad it is now how
bad is that well there's this term one
divided by 1 minus gamma
how big is that well this depends on
gamma obviously and there's this useful
heuristic that we briefly talked about
earlier in the course as well where you
can kind of view this as a horizon
where if gamma is 0.9 for instance
then 1 minus gamma is 0.1 and then 1
divided by 0.1 is 10. so if your gamma
point 9 roughly corresponds to a horizon
of 10
so that means that in that case if your
gamma is 0.9 the monte carlo error can
be 10 times smaller than the td error
but it looks right it can be at most 10
times smaller because this says that the
the error that td reaches is smaller or
equal to this thing right so it could be
of course in some cases you can have
feature representations for instance for
which td actually happens to find the
same solution as monte carlo
this is just saying in the worst case if
for instance your gamma your discount
factor is 0.9 in the worst case it could
be 10 times larger doesn't mean it
necessarily is 10 times larger
now you may have noticed that i already
said a couple of times if it converges
so there's a slight well but potentially
big problem here there's a fundamental
problem and it's a really interesting
one
and it's related to the following fact
that the temporal difference earning
update is not a true gradient update
and this is due to this it's highlighted
a lot lightly in the slide here to this
bootstrapping because the bootstrapping
uses the same parameters as the
parameters that we're updating with this
update
but we're kind of ignoring that in the
update we basically just plug that in as
a proxy for the real return and hope for
the best in some sense but i'll show you
an example where this can go wrong
normally this is okay it's okay when i
say this is okay i mean it's okay that
it's not a gradient update sometimes
people
people like things to be gradients
because we understand gradients quite
well we know stochastic gradient descent
converges so if we have something that's
not a gradient it sometimes is of some
concern so it's good to appreciate that
there's this broader class of algorithms
called stochastic approximation
algorithms which include gradient
algorithms stochastic gradient descent
as a special case but that's not the
only special case that necessarily
converges and indeed temporal difference
learning can converge to its fixed point
so stochastic approximation algorithms
are a broader class and there are
specific conditions under which these do
converge
stochastic gradient always converges
under fairly light
assumptions such as that the noise is
bounded the step size decays and your
data is stationary and so on
but temporal difference learning does
not
and now i'm going to show you an example
in which it doesn't
so this is an example of divergence of
temporal difference learning where we
have two states
and our feature vector has exactly one
element
and this feature vector has
an element equal to one in the first
state and the same element is equal to
two in the second state
what this means is it is depicted above
the states is our value estimate in the
first state is just w
because it's it's just this number w
which is just also a single number
because our feature factors also also
only has one element right and we're
doing linear function approximation here
so our value in the first state is w and
the value in the second state is 2w
because it's just the same number w
times your feature which is two
the reward along the way is zero it's a
simple problem
but now we're going to consider it's
it's a partial problem right i didn't
say what happens after you reach uh
states
where the feature vector is two
i just go i'm just going to consider
this one transition and then let's see
what happens if we apply td
so let's step through that let's just
first write down the td equation this is
our update for the for the temporal
difference sorry temporal disorder
update for our parameters of the value
function
where the value function gradient in the
linear case is just our feature
and in this case the reward is zero
the value of the subsequent state s
prime is the value of that state on the
right which is 2w for whatever w is
currently and the value that we're
updating so the value of the state that
we came from is just
x times w where x is 1 so that will just
be w
so we've just filled in these numbers
here this 0 goes over here this 2w goes
over here or
maybe more precisely this 2 goes over
there
and then the w comes in because we want
the value estimates and then this one
goes over here so there's 2w minus 1w
with a discount factor as well
and we can slightly rewrite this by
pulling out the w and getting rid of
that 0 which we don't really need to
consider
so then it turns out that this update
looks as follows where we have our
previous weight estimates plus your
learning rate whatever that is times two
minus discount minus one times whatever
your feature vector is sorry whatever
your weight factor is your weight number
which only has one number here
but what does this mean well let's
consider that your weight is positive
let's say you initialize it at one
and let's consider a discount factor
which is larger than a half
if the discount factor is larger than a
half this term within the brackets will
be positive
if your weight is positive and this term
within the bracket is positive and again
the weight here is positive
all of this
will be positive and in fact this whole
term here on the right will be added to
the previous weight which means our new
weight will be larger than the previous
weight
but the weight was already positive so
we're moving away from zero note the
true value function here
would be zero like the true value of
that first state might be zero at least
it's consistent with this with this
transition for it to be zero
you can expand this example to actually
have a fixed point of zero
but in this case it will just continue
to grow and your weight in the limit
will actually reach infinity
what's actually even worse it tends to
grow faster and faster
because your weight keeps going up and
this term multiplies with your weight
so this is this is an example of a
problematic behavior of temporal
difference learning and now we can dig
into why this has happened when this has
happened how can we characterize this
and how can we maybe avoid this
so what's happening here is that we're
actually combining multiple different
things at the same time we're combining
bootstrapping we're bootstrapping on
that state value on the right we're
combining off policy learning and i'll
explain that a little bit more and we're
combining function approximation and
when you combine these three things
together
you can get these divergent dynamics
this is sometimes called the deadly
triad because you need all three for
this to matter for this to become a
problem
the off policy learning i promised i
would say something about that why did i
say this is off policy there's there's
no policies here there's no actions here
so what's happening here well there's a
certain dynamics and your dynamics would
give you get you from this one state to
the other state
but then what we're actually doing is
we're going to resample that transition
over and over and we're never going to
sample any transitions that come from
the states
that we've entered just now right
and that is of policy in the sense that
they're actually in this case there are
no policies that would sample the states
over and over again specifically that
way so what we're doing instead we have
an off policy distribution of our
updates
this can emerge why this is called off
policy is this can emerge if you're
trying to predict the value of a certain
policy while following a different
policy
for instance it could be that the value
from this state that there are actions
but we're just not interested in their
values and hence they get kind of zeroed
out in your update in some sense
now we could also consider on policy
updating by extending the example to be
a full example
and now we consider this second
transition as well and let's for
instance assume that this transition
just terminates with a reward of zero
and then maybe you get transitioned back
to this first stage so maybe you just
see this episode over and over and over
again but now we sample on policy which
means we actually sample the transition
going from the second state as often as
we sample the transition going to that
state
if that is the case turns out the the
learning dynamics in general are
convergent td learning will converge
also with linear function approximation
if you're updating on policy
i will show that here just for the
example where we can just write out
maybe the combined update for simplicity
so let's just consider this transition
and let's immediately consider that
other transition and let's just write
down both of those updates where the
second transition bootstraps on the
terminal state with value zero also has
a reward of zero along the way so this
will then
basically only retain that value of that
state
and if we merge these together we get
this update to our weights and note that
the term inside here
is now negative for any discount factor
uh smaller or equal to one
which means that if your weight happened
to be positive it would push it down if
your weight happens to be negative it
will push it up
and that is exactly what we want in this
case because the optimal weight here is
zero just in this example right not
generally the case but in this example
it's zero and we can see that the
dynamics are such that indeed if you're
larger than zero you'll get pushed
towards zero if you're below zero you
will also get pushed towards zero so
this seems to be working and indeed it
has been proven in general that on
policy temporal difference voting with
linear function approximation will
converge to the optimal policy that's
already the optimal values
in terms of its fixed point right so the
fixed point of td is still different
from monte carlo but if we consider that
fixed point to be the goal it will find
that fixed point
in the on policy case
as i mentioned the multiplier here is
negative for any discount factor between
zero and one
okay
so off policy is a problem on policy
fixes it let's dig into one of the other
aspects i also mentioned function
approximation as one aspect of this so
let's see what happens if we don't
function approximation so we can
consider a tabular representation where
in each state we do have a feature
vector i've basically just denoted it as
a feature vector but it's one hot
picking out exactly that state
if we do that this is just regression
and this will also converge
the answer might be suboptimal but no
divergence occurs
so again td might have a different fixed
point in the tablet case it doesn't
actually have a different fixed point in
general it can have a different fixed
point but we could
by playing with a representation we
could go from divergent dynamics to
conversion dynamics that's the point
here tabular being a special
case so we can still updates
of policy now importantly right we don't
need to update on policy so we can go
back to just updating the first state
if we would do that
then the value of that state will
convert to whatever the discounted value
of the next state is
and we would never update that value
so this is a different way in which you
can have a different answer
because we're considering off policy
learning of course with function
approximations can also interact
but even in the tabular case it could be
that because you're learning off policy
that you simply ignore certain states
and therefore never update their values
which might have lingering effects in
the tabular values of the other states
so that's just like something to maybe
be a little bit aware of that this can
still affect where your solution is but
you won't diverge you'll still convert
to something
so that works too we had off policing is
on policiness we had function
approximation or not and now let's go to
the third one what if we don't bootstrap
or what if we bootstrap less because i
said there were three off policy
learning function approximation and
bootstrapping now let's look at the
bootstrapping and one way to do
bootstrapping is to use multi-step
returns
so let's consider now to have a lab
return we're still considering off
policy updates right so we're only
sampling this one transition over here
in some sense
but instead of calling it just sampling
that one transition let's say it a bit
more precisely we're only updating this
first state we're never actually
updating the second state but now let's
consider taking a ladder return from
that state instead of taking a one step
return
this is again something that can happen
in some sense in the wild enough policy
learning
and then we can just write that out we
have the laba return here which we know
bootstraps slightly on that first state
and also slightly continues
but it continues to v
s double prime which in this case is
this
terminal state so v prime sorry s prime
here is this second state and s double
prime is then this terminal state so now
we can fit in all these numbers that we
know we know that the reward on every
step is zero so r is r prime is zero and
also the value of this
state after two steps will be zero
we can just fill in all the numbers that
we know and we get this thing
and now we can analyze that thing so
it's very similar to what we had before
but before labda was basically zero so
before when we were talking about the
divergent example we had two gamma minus
one now we have two gamma times one
minus lambda minus one ah we have a
parameter that we can play with we can
play with this lava parameter
turns out we can always make sure that
this multiplier is negative which we
need here for conversions if we pick the
labda parameter in a specific way so
what we want is essentially that this
whole term is negative which means that
we want this term to be smaller than one
then we just rearrange move things
around and it turns out the condition
for that will be that your ladder is
larger than one
minus one over two gamma
just to be clear this is not a generic
finding this is just specifically for
this example this this relationship
we're just going through the example
so for instance we could pick a specific
discount we could fix it discount being
0.9 then turns out the lab the parameter
that we need to ensure that we have
convergence is that you need to pick it
larger than four over nine you can just
figure that out by plugging in zero
point nine here
and then just doing the math and
figuring out what to discount sorry what
the trace parameter lab that should be
this is not a hugely large trace
parameter typically people pick things
like 0.9 or 0.8 or something like that
so 0.45 is not an unreasonable value to
have if you pick it larger than that
you're good to go and you won't diverge
so these are important things to keep in
mind and one thing that i want to
highlight by going through all of these
things is that it's actually
it's not always binary so the deadly
tribe might make it sound that if you
combine bootstrapping function
approximation and off policy means that
you're always in trouble that's not
actually true you can combine
bootstrapping
function approximation and of policy
learning as long as you're not
bootstrapping too much you're not too
off policy and your function
approximation is tabular enough in some
sense
so what turns out to be the case is that
people run these algorithms in practice
quite a lot
and a lot of deeper algorithms actually
combine all these three things they
combine bootstrapping of policy learning
and function approximation where the
function approximation is for instance
deep neural networks you have policies
for instance because we try to predict
many different policies or because we're
trying to learn about past data
and things like that or because we're
just doing q learning at scale which is
also an off policy algorithm
and then the bootstrapping is also
because fringe is doing q learning or
doing something similar but also because
of this bias variance tradeoff that we
typically find that it's better not to
bootstrap
too heavily but also not to use full
monte carlo returns
so we're combining all of these but
turns out many of these algorithms are
actually stable and they do learn well
because we're not we're still in the
triad but we're not in the deadly
portion of the triad
an alternative that you could consider
is to pick a different loss
so let me briefly go into there
so temporal difference learning has a
specific update right and i mentioned
all temporal difference learning can
diverge if you're doing uh all of these
things at the same time
but why do temporal difference learning
can we find something else maybe
okay so the problem as mentioned from
temporal difference learning is that it
ignores essentially that we're
bootstrapping on a value that itself
depends on the weights
what was happening in the example that
we had just now going from a state with
value w to state with 2w was essentially
that we're trying to update this state
closer to the value of that next state
but in doing so we're actually updating
the value of the next state more away
from us so you're chasing your own tail
except your tail is running away from
you faster than you're running towards
it that's why td in that case diverges
so an alternative would be to actually
define something that is a gradient a
true gradient
one example of this is the bellman
residual gradient algorithm where we
define a loss which is just our square
td error so this is a different loss
right we don't have our normal value
loss here we don't have a normal value
error we instead say well let's just
consider the temporal difference error
and let's see if we can minimize that
if you push the gradient through that
and you calculate that you find
something that looks very similar to d
but had to td but has a different
additional term
unfortunately this tends to work worse
in practice and one reason for that is
it smooths your value estimates where
stem for difference learning in some
sense predicts
so what do i mean there intuitively
temporal difference learning updates the
value of the state towards something
that is in the future towards this
one-step estimate of your value in the
future the reward and the value the next
state
this algorithm instead it's a fine
algorithm it can be used and it's
convergent in as much as sample
difference learning sorry as stochastic
gradient descent
is convergent
but it does something that is maybe a
little bit weird in the sense that it
updates not just the value of the state
that we came from but it also update the
value of the state that we're
bootstrapping on
so in that sense it's a smoother because
what it might do is actually it might
pull downs for instance the value of the
state you're bootstrapping on just to
make it easier to predict it but that
doesn't mean that's a valid value for
that state so it turns out if you run
these algorithms in practice
oftentimes it just works worse
that's maybe not a necessity maybe it's
not necessarily worse but it's basically
seems to be that this loss
although we can define a gradient of
that loss which looks somewhat similar
to the td algorithm that maybe the loss
is just not the right thing to be
minimizing it might not be the right
thing to look at
so smooth values are not just bad
because your value accuracy might be
slightly wrong but it might also
actually lead to sub-optimal decisions
this is especially true if your rewards
are for instance sparse because then
there might be this one rewarding event
and immediately after getting the reward
your value function maybe should drop
because you've already received that
reward but if you do something like
bellman residual minimization what might
actually happen is it tends to smooth
over that discontinuity in the value
function and hence the states
immediately after already taking the
reward
might be updated to look a little bit
like they might still be able to take
some of the reward which might lead to
wrong decisions
so let's consider a different
alternative let's instead of squaring
the td error inside the expectation
let's just take the expected td error
and try to minimize that if we minimize
the expected td error maybe we're still
kind of good to go from a prediction
perspective
and instead of
so
so let me just go back a slide let me
show the one difference here is where
this query is right so here in the
bellman residual algorithm the square is
inside the expectation
here when we consider the bellman era
these squares outside of the expectation
again we can take the gradient of this
but there's a catch and the gradient
looks very similar to the previous
algorithm but there's this weird s prime
there
s prime is a second independent sample
of s t plus one so s prime t plus one
needs to be sampled separately if you
don't sample it separately you're
actually doing this other algorithm that
we talked about before
where st plus one is the actual next
state that you've seen
so this algorithm can only be applied if
you have a simulator that you can reset
you should be able to sample the
transition twice essentially
and then you could apply it but that's
an unrealistic assumption for many cases
if you're a robot in the real world and
you're just interacting with the world
you can't resample the transition twice
so then this uh this algorithm becomes
less feasible
here's just a brief summary of what we
were just talking about
there's a couple of different categories
so you have your algorithm which could
be monte carlo or it could be td you
could be on policy or it could be off
policy and you could pick a certain
function class
now in terms of just summarizing the
convergence properties of these
algorithms if you're on policy your
message is good to go the only thing
that's not 100 guaranteed is non-linear
conversions but even for that one we can
say some things actually and in some
cases you can guarantee that td
converges for the non-linear case but it
requires more assumptions so we can't
say in general it always converges
if we go off policy we see that linear
function approximation also becomes
problematic for td
although again i want to stress that
this doesn't mean it's always a problem
it just means there are cases in which
we can't guarantee convergence doesn't
mean the algorithm doesn't work in
general just means that there are
educators in which you could do
something wrong
this has been addressed in more recent
work that is too detailed to go into in
this lecture where people have devised
new algorithms that are slightly
different from td but might be inspired
by td that are actually guaranteed to
converge
also with function approximation also
under off policy updating but those
algorithms are beyond the scope of this
this lecture and this course section
okay so now let's move towards control
so now that i've maybe
[Music]
expressed some uncertainty about
convergence but also some
evidence that typically does converge
so
we can extend all of these control
algorithms obviously to function
approximation
the theory of control with function
approximation is not that well developed
unfortunately this is because it's
substantially harder from a prediction
case because now the uh the policies
under direct control this might change
over time and it might be quite hard to
uh reason through maybe the one
exception of this will be in a
subsequent lecture when we talk about
policy gradients which are again
stochastic gradient algorithms and
therefore are in some sense fine but the
theory of control with function
approximation when you use value
estimates is much
harder in some sense
in addition to that actually we might
not even want to converge that often or
during learning especially when
considering this value learning because
you might actually want to continue
tracking
so for instance if you're
if you're doing something like
value-based control
you your policy will be changing so your
predictions shouldn't converge because
they want to convert to whatever the
current value of the policy is but if
the policy keeps changing you actually
want to track that rather than converge
but also more generally even if we're
doing direct updates to the policy it
might be preferable to actually not
converge but just to continue to adapt
that doesn't mean that convergence
guarantees are not interesting or not
important because one thing that we
could still have is if we have a
guarantee of convergence that means that
the algorithm kind of updates stably
typically throughout its lifetime
whereas if you can diverge you only need
to diverge one once for everything to
fall apart obviously so understanding
when things converge and diverge is
still very important even if you can't
fully characterize it
okay now moving on we're going to
consider updating these functions in
batch settings
so we've talked about batch methods
previously
but there's a different reason we're
going to talk about it now previously
when we talked about that's
reinforcement learning this was
basically to highlight differences
between temporal difference learning and
monte carlo learning
but we weren't proposing it as an
approach that you should necessarily
follow although we didn't mention that
you could do that
now we're going to take the other view
which is oh what if we really want to
learn um
with
batches of data and a reason why you
might want to do that is because well
gradient descent is a simple and
appealing algorithm it's not very simply
efficient the reason why intuitively is
that every time you see a transition
you're going to consume that transition
and make maybe an incremental update to
your value function
and then you're going to toss the
transition away
but there might be a lot that you could
have learned from that transition that
you can't immediately extract it doesn't
play a role immediately in the update
that you're doing
and then that would be a waste in a
sense
so instead we could consider to doing a
batch approach where we try to find the
best fitting value function for a set of
data that we've seen so far so instead
of just doing one gradient update
necessarily on every sample
we could try to maybe extract as much
information as we possibly can from the
training data
there are several ways to do that i just
want to mention that if
[Music]
if this seems at odds with our main goal
at the beginning where the world is
large your lifetime is large and
consider a robot walking through the
world
maybe you're thinking well that robots
can't store all the data
this is true i and i agree with that
viewpoint
so
full batch settings are maybe most
typically employed when the data is not
too huge but turns out you can also
employ them in practice by for instance
storing only a limited amount of data
or alternatively this will actually also
be related to model-based approaches
where you can consider storing some of
the data to be quite similar to storing
an empirical model so now it's just a
choice of what your model is
what the structure of your model is is
it a parametric model or is it a
non-parametric model that consists only
of data that you've seen
so there are approaches that feel quite
similar to these batch approaches that
do scale to really large problems where
maybe you couldn't store all the data
but for now for simplicity and clarity
we're going to focus on this case where
we really are going to consider all the
data and we will actually see that there
are some methods that don't actually
need to store all the data to get the
same answer and we're going to start
there by considering again the linear
case so we have linear function
approximation
and we were considering fitting the best
possible fit of our parameters so we
talked about this before in the limits
for td
so let's consider that td
update again and what we said is oh if
you consider the updates to have
converged so that the expected update is
zero then your fixed point will be this
this weight
vector which we called wtd which is as
defined on the slide this is the same as
we saw earlier
now one idea that you could do is well
what if we take that expectation and
instead of taking the expectation over
all possible states and all possible
transitions that could happen
let's just take it over the things that
did happen
so what we'll do here are add some time
step t
and we're just going to instead of
taking the full expectation which we
don't know for this we would need the uh
knowledge of the mark of decision
process instead what we're going to do
we're going to take the average of the
things that did actually happen
so this is very similar and in the limit
of course this average if time grows to
infinity if your distribution is
stationary which needs to be the case
for this expectation to even exist then
this summation this equation actually
will converge to this equation
above
by law of large numbers assuming of
course that the variance of your reward
is finite and so on
so the idea then is to maybe instead of
doing this where we just use this for
analysis we are going to do exactly the
same things on the empirical loss and
that turns out this will look as follows
where we see something very similar as
we did for the
td fixed point so for the td fixed point
let me walk you through that first we
had the expectation over an outer
product of two vectors so the first
vector is just a feature vector and the
second vector is your feature vector
minus the next feature vector discounted
and this is an outer product so this is
a matrix
and the expectation over that will be a
full rank matrix typically under some
mild assumptions so we can invert it and
then we multiply that with a vector so
we have a matrix number of features by
number of features
times a vector number of features and
that will give us a weight vector this
is also the number of features large
which fits with the linear function
approximation of course
now here we're going to do exactly the
same thing but instead of having the
expectation we have summations
note that we're not not taking averages
because if we would put like a one
divided by t here and we would put one
over here they would just cancel out so
we can ignore that we can just consider
the sum of these other products and the
sum of these vectors over here
and that will be equivalent to taking
the average instead
so the summation is over exactly what
you would expect now which is this outer
product of these feature vectors but
it's not for the expected feature
vectors it's for the ones that you've
actually seen
and then again here the same thing
happens
this is called least squares temporal
difference learning and the solution
here this weight vector is the least
square solution given some data
so
we can put that equation here at the top
of the slide where i made one change
here in the previous slide i called it
wlstd
and now i'm just going to call it wt
because in fact we can change this as we
get more data wt can change because it's
just a data dependent weight and indeed
we could be interested in these
predictions for
uh any time set during learning right so
there might be reasons why you might
want to extract this prediction for
instance for reasons of control you
might want to pick actions
although that's a bit more subtle to do
to combine with least question for
difference learning because in some
sense you don't want to consider all the
data then because these this is
collected with overpass policies
so for simplicity now consider the
prediction case but it could be that you
still want to know these value functions
as you go so you might want to have this
weight vector you might want to compute
it you get some new data you want to
recompute it
now unfortunately we can do that online
so before we do that let's just give
these things names we call the matrix
here inside the brackets a
so that this whole thing will be a
inverted so a t is just this summation
of outer products
bt will be the summation of the feature
vector times the reward
so these are the names we give it and
then the weight vector at every time
step is defined as the inverse of a t
times bt
now we can update both of these online
so we're considering actually storing
both these separate quantities and we're
going to update a separately from bt and
then recompute wt whenever we need it
one way to do that the naive approach
and maybe the most obvious way to do
that would be to update the a matrix by
just adding the current
outer product the one you've just
observed and adding the reward times
feature vector to the b vector
unfortunately the reason i call this the
naive approach is that it's fairly
expensive
it's not expensive because of the b
update that one's very cheap because
that one just has the same number of
operations as you have features
x here is just a feature vector b is the
same size as a feature vector we're just
adding two vectors together and this
gives us our new vector
the update to a is more expensive
because we're adding an outer product
which is will be
our other products of these feature
vectors will be the same size as a
matrix by features by number of features
and we're adding this to this a matrix
this is also
the size of the feature squared
so adding these together and giving us
our new a matrix is n squared where n is
the number of features
so that is also not the most expensive
operation here the most expensive
operation is then that when we want to
compute w we need to invert a and
inverting a naively will give us a cubic
cost because a will be some dense
matrix and inverting a square
matrix of n by n will be cubic in n
so that's expensive and we want to avoid
that
and the reason we want to avoid that is
because we want to ultimately consider
large feature vectors
so if you only have 10 features you
could apply this approach right then the
algorithm would cost like 100
computations to compute your weight
vector sorry a thousand computations
updating b would only be like 10
operations order 10 operations updating
a would be order 100 operations but an
inverting a would be order a thousand
operations that's still okay but if you
have a million features this becomes
very uh
very wild very quickly and it's not very
very scalable approach
um
so we'd like to do something a little
bit cheaper turns out you can do exactly
the same thing cheaper by updating the
inverse of the matrix a instead of the
matrix a itself
and this is called a sherman morrison
update
and sherman morrison is a more generic
approach where we can take any matrix
and then add any outer products and then
consider the matrix that results from
that operation and then turns out the
inverse of that matrix can be computed
in only
squared number of operations if you knew
the inverse of the matrix that we had
before
so we just we we always have this
because we're incrementally keeping we
keep them updating it
so we just start for instance
at the um you can start for instance at
um
something simple like the identity
and then
you could just incrementally keep on
updating like this
so the operations here are um as you can
see a matrix by another matrix here's an
outer product by another matrix
of course you could also first compute
the dot product of the vector with the
matrix turning that into a vector and
then you still have the same happening
here so then you'd still have an outer
product left the thing below the
division bar is just a scalar because
it's a vector times a matrix times a
vector plus one
so this is a it looks maybe a little bit
complicated there are many proofs of why
sherman morrison works online feel free
to dig into that if you didn't see this
before the update to b remains the same
we don't need to invert b it's just a
vector you can't invert that
and this way we would be able to compute
this w this weight vector at the top of
the slide by incrementally updating the
inverse of a rather than a itself
this is still quadratic in the number of
features and it applies only to linear
function approximation but it is it is
an approach that scales at least to some
larger numbers than the cubic approach
it is more computed than td so in large
applications this is still avoided for
two reasons one is that it's limited to
the linear case as i mentioned and the
other one is that you might still want
to have very large feature vectors even
if you want to do linear and if your
feature vectors are a million
size a million then still
squaring that is still fairly large so
it might still take quite a bit of time
on every step
however it could be that
this is feasible for your application
and then it's
it's good to keep keep it in mind the
other reason why we talk about this is
because it can be an inspiration to
other approaches
so in the limits it's good to appreciate
that lcd and td converts to the same
fixed point for lcd this is almost
immediate
let me just go back a couple of slides
to show that because as i said by the
law of large numbers this thing will
just become that thing which means that
the solutions will also become the same
so lcd kind of immediately
will converge to the same fixed point
std under mild assumptions
and we can extend lcd to multi-step
returns as well we could consider lstd
lab that instead of just considering the
one-step lcd video we discussed just now
it can also be extended to action values
maybe quite naturally you consider you
can always
almost always extend anything that's
defined for state values to state action
values by considering sarsa-like
approaches
and then of course we can interlace it
with policy improvement if we do that we
could have least squares policy
iteration
where we just use lstdq to estimate
action values for the policy evaluation
phase and then we greetify the algorithm
of course when we do that when we change
the algorithm we need to be a little bit
careful that we then shouldn't use all
the data collected so far
for computing our value estimates one
approach one simple approach could for
instance be that you just restart the
policy policy evaluation phase whenever
you've made a policy improvement step
throwing away the past values not
trusting them anymore and just
recompusing them for the new policy
okay now we're going to move on to maybe
what is maybe a more generic approach
but it's similar to lscd in the sense
that we're going to consider the data
collected so far
so we consider that we have some
experience a data set consisting of all
of our experience up to some time set t
now one thing we could do is instead of
considering all of these transitions at
once as we were doing with lstd
we can just sample transitions from this
data set repeatedly
so we sample transition that's
enumerator with a with a time step n
which is smaller or equal to the current
time set t
and then we just do a gradient update
with that
so if this data was collected under
certain policy and we're interested in
evaluating that policy this seems like a
fine approach
you can actually also combine it with q
learning and i'll show that in a moment
to learn off policy
the benefit of this is that you can
reuse old data
so you could just store all the data
you've seen so far and keep on updating
which means you can take multiple steps
on the same multiple gradient steps
incremental gradient steps on the same
transitions over and over and thereby
extract more knowledge that you maybe
could do from a single gradient step
this is also a form of batch learning it
doesn't consider all the data at once it
doesn't consider the full batch at once
but instead it considers the batch to be
able to sample from it
of course you have to be a little bit
careful that if your policy changes
this might be important because if
you're just trying to do prediction you
don't want to use transitions for a
policy that has uh has now changed or
alternatively in a
future lecture i'll talk about how to
deal with that and how to still be able
to use it but to re-weight it
appropriately
ok this brings us to the exciting topic
of deep reinforcement burning i will
touch upon that only briefly now there
will be much more about this in later
lectures
so
i'm going to start by just doing a very
very brief um kind of a recap
on
neural networks in general
this might be very familiar to many of
you already but it seemed useful just to
very briefly go into that a little bit
so let's go to the uh
note-taking
app
that we've been calling a blackboard
and let's consider
what deep neural networks essentially
are as far as we're concerned there's a
lot to say about this and of course i
won't be able to say anything remotely
scratching the surface but let me just
give you the very bare minimum that that
might be useful for us to understand for
the purposes of this course
so what have we been considering so far
let's first start with the linear case
and we were considering to having a
value function that is defined as an
inner product of some weight vector w
with some features of the state
now this is a linear approach which has
benefits and downsides as discussed
before
what would be a non-linear approach well
for instance we could have
some function
let's say f
that takes some number as input and
outputs a real number
and we could apply that we could say
that any such function
um actually let me make it clear that
these are both just numbers
so
any such function let's just assume that
without
bothering if we apply this to a vector
then it will be applied element-wise so
the idea is that we have some function
which is non-linear
popular examples of this
include
let me just draw a couple squashing
functions so if this is the
zero lines
of a graph then the squashing function
might look like this
or another popular choice these days is
what they call a rectifier linear unit
which has a discontinuity that looks
like this
where essentially
um
it's
this this one is just defined as
f
y is
max
zero y
and the benefit of this is that it's
linear in some parts
but it has a non-linearity so you can
use this to add non-linearity to your
function if you want and i'll show you
in a minute how
um this one's often called a sigmoid
or the one i actually
this is more general term the one i drew
here or kind of tried to draw here
kind of
is
a 10 inch
um
so that's those are just specific
functions and the idea is that this is
some nonlinear function and then one way
to make that value function on linear is
just to apply that function so we could
consider something like this where we
have a function applied
now this is not particularly useful yet
right but it's already non-linear and if
f is differentiable
then we can still compute its gradient
with respect to the weights
now this is not very useful immediately
why would we necessarily for instance
squash the function between 0 and 1 as
we do with the 10h or why would we say
oh negative values are not allowed as we
do with a rectifier so this one's called
a rectifier
linear unit
no so this is not typically what we do
so let me immediately correct that
instead what we might do is we might say
well let's first apply some matrix to
our features or inputs
sorry we don't need a transpose there
so i'm starting the neural transform
and then we multiply this again so let
me call this waitress matrix
1
and then we have maybe a vector
2
and this could be our value estimate
so now note that if we want to take the
gradient so the gradient with one of the
components of w uh
2 will be quite simple so if we consider
the partial derivative of
vw
of some state s
with respect to w to
i
this will simply be
the function f
applied to
this weight matrix
applied to our feature vector
taken at
i so note here that this weight matrix
multiplied by the feature vector the
feature vector is a vector the matrix is
matrix so the output of this is a vector
so f is applied element-wise and we're
basically going to subscript this with
an i to denote that we're taking the i
input uh the output here
there's different ways to denote that i
could have also written this for
instance with uh
index notation like that
so that's very similar to before
essentially
as far as we're concerned now in terms
of the derivative with respect to the
weights in w2
these are just features so our features
are now defined as some function f
applied to some weight matrix w times
the feature vector
and those are as far as we're concerned
just our features
but the difference now is that we can
also consider as part of our update the
gradients
so the
the partial derivative
with respect to some
element in matrix one so let's consider
for instance i and j so it's a matrix
right
so we need to
[Music]
index twice to get one element
and this can be computed just by the
chain rule so what we'll get is
essentially
that will
have the gradient of
w
vw
by
the intermediate thing so we take the
gradient of the intermediate thing being
um
this one taken at
i
and then that thing
[Music]
the gradient with respect to that
weight but let's do an intermediate step
let's take it first just to the inputs
of that function
and then finally we have
so let's unpack this a little bit so
this part this first partial derivative
is just the gradient of our value
function with respect to the i feature
in some sense this will just be w2
at i
this next part is just the derivative
of our
function whatever that is
and these functions above they always
have some well-defined derivative
the radius doesn't actually have a
well-defined derivative at exactly zero
but that's okay we just define it to be
zero there so we extend this to have a
well-defined derivative at zero so that
the derivative at least is not contained
not discontinuous
sorry let me move down again
so this will just be the derivative
taken at whatever those values were
and then this last bit
the weight matrix times the feature
vector by that one element
will simply be
feature vector indexed at
that one element
so these are all just numbers now sorry
this was also taken at
i so note that actually what we're
considering here so i've indexed here
let me use a different color to denote
that
here i've indexed with i which i did
here as well
i could also have written that as this
like the f is applied to
the weight matrix
but indexed at i so let me just say i
dot so now it's a vector
so that's a different way to write that
same thing
so essentially whenever i index here um
so let me actually pull that one inside
let me get rid of that one over there
and let me instead put it over there
to make it clearer
that we're actually indexing the weight
matrix
now note that the things that we're left
with then at the bottom they're all just
numbers this is a number that is a
number that is a number and we just
multiply them together to get that one
number that we needed for our gradient
then our gradient is just this one big
vector which merges
both the
contributions for
the second weight vector and for the
weight matrix and we can continue
stacking this now i mentioned before
it's useful to go through these steps to
apply the chain rule a little bit but
you don't have to actually worry too
much about that in practice these days
because what we instead do
we just whenever we need a gradient we
apply a software package which will
automatically compute that gradient so
you can make these functions arbitrarily
complex
so one thing that you could do is for
instance you could have a
value function
that has some
weight
let's say at layer l
times the feature sorry so this is just
some function which we could also
super subscript l where this is a layer
index
and then
this will be
times the inputs let's call those y at
layer l
and then we could just say oh the inputs
at layer l are defined as some weight
matrix l this is a vector so now we have
a matrix
of l minus 1
times the
features
at the previous
so we can stack this fairly deeply
just expand it for one specific example
let me just write it down explicitly
because it doesn't hurt
to uh
have that in mind
for instance we could have something
like three layers let's say
and the more layers you add when we use
terminology in deep learning we say the
deeper your network is
this is because you can denote this this
function you can denote that as there
being an inputs
x
and then there's a weight matrix here
and then we get our
let's say that like
let's give this a name
sorry
ran out of space there on the
on the end let's give this one a name i1
then this could be i2
and then
you could do that again
i3
and then maybe then
so we could denote notice as well by
showing that there's lots of connections
here
this could be a dense matrix operation
and then in the end maybe it goes into a
single number
where this is weight three
so the idea is that you can stack these
people use all sorts of notations to
denote these neural networks sometimes
as simple as something like this
or sometimes people draw more
complicated figures which show the
dimensions a little bit better
as you can imagine you can make these
things fairly complex and weird looking
as well
so you could have all sorts of
weird structures which merge in strange
ways because maybe you want to somehow
put some inductive bias in the structure
of your value function this can be
useful in some cases is this is a way to
put for instance some more prior
knowledge into your function class if
that is helpful it could also be that
you have multiple inputs that maybe come
in at multiple places for instance you
could have vision inputs and auditory
inputs and maybe division input has a
certain pre-processing necessarily and
then the auditory inputs have a
different preprocessing necessary so you
could have all sorts of inputs like
maybe this is
some part of your observation this is a
different part of your observation
maybe this is yet another part of your
observation and they finally all come
together to give you your value estimate
and then all parameters here
in your network so actually let me do
that in a different color to make it
clear that we're not
that this is not part of the network now
so oh sorry that didn't
actually change my
color
yes
doesn't seem to want to change my color
so let's go like that
so all of those
lines there there are there are weights
so we just compute the gradient with
respect to those weights
and typically these days as i mentioned
we use an auto differentiation package
to do that so you can basically
construct these fairly complicated
networks without having to worry about
computing all of these gradients by hand
instead the software will do that for us
and turns out these gradients can always
be computed if you're if you're using
differentiable functions of course these
can always be computed in a compute that
is comparable to the amount of compute
it takes to do your forward pass so if
you can do that as forward pass of this
whole network in some limited amount of
time and then computing the gradient
will take a time that is proportional to
that so it doesn't take much longer to
compute the gradient
okay now that's
in a nutshell deep learning i want to
say one more thing which is if we then
consider time september time step you
could consider having a state here
this is our asian state now
and let's go a time step further to the
next aging state
and these depend somehow on our
observations
and maybe agent state is then used in
some complicated way maybe they also
results from your
observation in some complicated way and
maybe these are used in some complicated
way to maybe get our value and maybe to
get our policy
and maybe other things as well
now
this step this agent update function
could be considered let me actually put
it somewhere else let me put that here
because the agent update function
in some sense
merges that arrow and this part so it
merges the observation in the previous
state into a new state that's the
definition of the agent update function
and here we see how we could structure
that in our implementations as a neural
network
where there is now a gradient that might
flow actually let me
use blue to denote the gradient flow so
if we want to update the prediction over
here
the gradient might flow into the
parameters here
into the parameters looking at the
observation
and also maybe through time
maybe even further back
so there could have been
then you use prime s to denote the
previous one
and the gradient could flow all the way
back
through time
now this is both nice and potentially
beneficial but it's also potentially
problematic because that means that if
you want to actually have the trading
flowing all the way through time you
need to do something smart about how
that gradient flows that's beyond the
scope of this uh course that's more
for more advanced deep learning
considerations there are mechanisms that
allow you to do that for instance by
just truncating the gradient flow at
some times up in the past and say well
i'm just going to do a couple of steps
that's called back propagation through
time
that propagation in general is just the
term refers to computables those
gradients going backwards through these
non-linear structures
okay so that's just a brief very brief
explanation of deep learning some of
that might be completely known to you
already if you're previous to a deep
learning curve course here i just wanted
to highlight that this is one way to
build these structures and that you can
then use them to uh
basically compute your value functions
i want to mention yet one more little
thing which is kind of the same as what
i said before which is what conf nets
are so the structure that we've seen
before actually let me highlight that
again
is a non-linear network now i'm just
going to say a special case of this is
when you have vision inputs which are
structured sometimes drawn
like this
where these are kind of the pixels on
the screen so maybe you have some sort
of a
pac-man thing here maybe trying to eat
the ghosts so of course normally you'd
see
much more of the pac-man screen but
let's just do a simple example
maybe there's a dot here that's eating
as well so this could be the pixels of
the screen and in fact typically you
could have multiple layers of these
because for instance you could have an
rgb input where one of these layers
contains the red one of them contains
the green and so on
and then what we can do
is we can apply a linear layer to this
and then do process through nonlinearity
exactly as before
but turns out if you just put all of
those into like you could take all these
these pixels and just put them into some
sort of a large
flat vector and then just do the the
thing that we did before
but that turns out that doesn't work
that well so we typically don't do that
so instead what we typically do is we
apply a special linear layer which
actually looks at a little patch
and typically looks at that patch
across the channels so these are
channels
so then it turns this little patch here
that goes through the channels in a
sense
it turns that into a vector and then
applies a weight matrix to give us the
next
patch
which then gets turned into
a spatial patch again
and potentially again you could have
multiple layers of those
and in fact what we typically do
is we don't actually turn it into a
patch we just turn it into a
so i'm actually going to backtrack that
slightly we just turn it into a number
so a little one pixel
and then having
stacked layers of those this is just a
vector but i'm stacking it
and then we're going to compose those
again into some larger image
the number of layers here the number of
sorry channels here
does not have to match
with the previous one so we could have
more channels here and the
semi image in some sense could be
smaller this is called the cons net and
then what happens in the columns is that
actually the same weights get to get
applied to different patches
so also over here
that's called weight sharing in general
and commons nets use weight sharing so
essentially what's happening here is you
could consider this to be kind of a
filter
and this filter gets moved across the
image
and
basically on every patch in the image it
gets applied the same filter and it
extracts some feature information which
passes it into a new feature layer
and then we get something that's
sometimes drawn a little bit like this
where as mentioned we could have
multiple planes here and then this goes
into
other planes
where these planes
could have a different numbers let me
just draw three this time
or four let me just
make it as i go along and this one patch
here
would show up as a single pixel in this
new thing but then there's an
overlapping patch for instance here
that would show up as the pixel just
next to it
and so on and so on
and then we just can do the same thing
again and then it could be a new patch
here
that goes into a layer above there
so you could apply this multiple times
these are just
similar to before these are just
linear layers and then we put
non-linearities basically
just before uh computing this uh
this pixel over here
so this would still have this
non-linearity on top of this because
otherwise it's a linear network and
everything kind of collapses to a linear
function approximator
but nonlinear function approximation can
be a richer class so instead of
necessarily being linear in the
observations this could now be nonlinear
observation
and then you can apply this many many
times and then eventually you could toss
it into a vector and then maybe compute
your value function on top of that
so that is all that the content is it's
exactly the same except that the linear
layer has some certain structure so one
way to consider that is that this matrix
here at the beginning
could be a common layer and that just
means that that matrix has a very
specific structure where the same
weights show up in multiple places in
the matrix there's weight sharing
and in addition there is some certain
specific spatial structure where we're
considering owning these patches
okay so that's
just a brief primer there's much more to
be said about this this is kind of a
poor explanation because we're only
taking a little bit of time to talk
about these aspects so i just wanted to
give you a flavor of it if you don't
fully understand that there's loads of
introductory material on deep learning
on the uh
in the wild and there's courses on this
there's lots of stuff on the internet so
i encourage you if you want to know more
please dig into that if you first want
to just continue with the rest of this
course without fully understanding all
of it that's also perfectly okay
okay so then using these networks
in reinforcement planning is called deep
reinforcement learning fortunately many
of the ideas immediately transfer when
using deep neural networks we can do
temporal difference learning we could do
monte carlo we just place the feature
vector with the gradient
in our updates we can apply double
learning if we need it for instance
double dqn
double q learning we could use
experience replay and all sorts of other
intuitions and results they do transfer
some things don't
for instance ucb is hard to transfer
because ucb i'm reminding you this is an
exploration method that we discussed in
the second lecture and it requires
counts so you need to know how often
you've seen a certain state or state
action pair if you want to ucb
turns out it's very hard to count with
deep neural networks or at least in in
the way that we need for ucb
because of generalization so deep neural
networks tend to generalize really well
and this makes them learn really quickly
and people are still trying to
understand exactly the properties of
these networks because it also depends
on which optimization mechanism you use
because these days people typically
don't use vanilla stochastic gradient
descent but they use gradient
transformations on top of that
now if you
whether you do that or not it turns out
it's just very hard to count with these
neural networks in terms of the states
and reinforcement learning and therefore
it's hard to apply some sort of a bound
like ucb does although people have
considered extensions that do seem to
maybe be somewhat reasonable but it's
still active research
also least squares methods don't really
transfer that well because they're
specifically made for the linear case
and then you can analytically compute
these compute these sorry these
solutions
but in the generic case for non-linear
functions it's really hard to compute
those solutions because there's
non-linearities involved that means that
we can't just immediately write down
what the optimal weight vector is for a
specific data set to fit it and instead
what people typically do is just use
gradient methods to incrementally find
them so instead of doing these squares
people do experience replay
so let me now walk you through an
example where an online neural q
learning agent that combines these
approach might include a neural network
which takes your observations and
outputs say an action out q value so the
idea is that this is just a non-linear
function that just looks at the pixels
of the screen let's say of pac-man and
then has some maybe conflares to first
do the spatial reasoning then merges
that into a vector that maybe has a
couple of other layers and then at the
end it outputs the same number of
elements as you have actions and then we
just index that with the action that
we're interested in if we want a
specific action value
now note that i have ignored agent state
here
so the agency is basically just your
observation in this case so this one
wouldn't have memory
and maybe that's okay for some games
like pac-man
then we need an exploratory policies for
instance we just do epsilon greedy on
top of this weight vector that we have
so that our
action that we actually select will be
greedy with respect to these action
values with probability one minus
epsilon and fully random with uh
probability epsilon
and then we have a way it updates to the
parameters of this network where we use
in this case gradient q learning
which you might recall the q learning
update let me just briefly mention it
again
it's going to be your immediate reward
plus the discounted
value of the maximum value action in the
next state minus our current estimate
times the gradient of that current
estimate that would be a gradient
extension of q learning
i did mention a couple of downsides like
overestimation you could plug in
solutions here as well this is just for
for giving you a simple example
then we could use an optimizer so
typically what people do is they take
this
this update according to std this
gradient in some sense it's a semi
gradient actually because of the way
it's also being here but being ignored
but but people take this and then they
transform it for instance applying
momentum so that you take a little bit
of the previous update and you merge
that in or using more fancy optimizers
like rms prop and the adam optimizer
those are quite popular these days
and then
turns out this often works better when
using deep neural networks details are
not too important for us right now
often when i said we were using these
other differentiation packages uh often
these days so what people quite often do
what you'll see in code quite often is
they implement this weight update via a
loss
but it's a little bit of aware of things
i'm mentioning this because it makes it
easier to understand versus other
people's code but in some sense it's a
little bit of a strange thing because
there's this really strange operator
here which is called a stop gradient in
most software frameworks so basically
what people do then is they say oh let's
just write it down as if it's a loss but
let's ignore the gradient flowing into
this part
and then if you take the gradient of
this thing but you ignore the gradient
going into this part you get that update
that we had above
this kind of makes it explicit that this
is not a real gradient algorithm right
we actually have to manually specify oh
yeah take the gradient but don't push
the gradient into that part
and if you do push the gradient into
that part you're doing one of these
bellman residual minimization
algorithms instead and as i mentioned
that tends to work slightly worse in
practice
so you could play with this you could
try that out and see if the same holds
for you that that works worse
and then people implement this as a loss
so they can say oh just minimize that
just apply stochastic gradient descent
on that
alternatively of course what you could
also do is you could just compute this
temporal difference error this q
learning temporal difference error here
and just compute the gradient with
respect to the action values then you
don't need that stop gradient operation
and then you could also implement it
like that what we're basically doing in
some sense there is akin to doing one
step of the chain rule by hand a very
simple first step of the chain rule by
hand
to construct the update directly instead
of first formulating it as some sort of
a loss
it's not a real loss it's not because of
the stop gradients i would i'm hesitant
to call that a real loss although people
do call these things real losses even if
people call these things losses even if
they're soft gradients
i'm just hesitant to do that because
we're not actually following the
gradient with respect to the parameters
if there are stock gradients involved
so this just happens to have the right
gradient if you compute this with an
auto differentiation package
that's just for awareness essentially if
you want to implement this
and now we can finally move to the dq
algorithm so i showed examples of this
all the way at the beginning of the
course where we saw this agent playing
atari games and now we finally
accumulated enough knowledge that we
could actually replicate that so i'm
going to explain what is in that
algorithm and it's very similar to what
we saw just now
so there's a neural network exactly as i
said just now the observation here
is a little bit special so the
observation in dqn is not just the
pixels on the screen
it's actually
taking a couple of frames a couple of
steps into the past and also doing some
operations on that so the original dqn
algorithm
would down scale the screen slightly for
computational reasons it would gray
scale it instead of keeping the color
information this actually throws away a
little bit of information some recent
approaches people sometimes don't do
that anymore
and in addition to that it would stack a
couple of frames so it has some slight
history and there are two reasons for
that one is for instance in a game like
pong where you're hitting a ball from
one pedal to the other it was thought
that maybe this is important to be able
to capture the direction of the ball
because if you just know where the ball
is then you don't necessarily
necessarily go whether it's going no
whether it's going left or right in the
game of pong that might not actually be
that consequential that might not be
necessary to know that for picking the
right action but in other games you
could imagine that sometimes that
information is quite useful but there's
a different reason as well which is that
india's atari games
in the simulator at least and maybe in
the original games as well i don't
actually know the screen would sometimes
flicker so certain enemies might
sometimes be there on one frame but they
wouldn't be there on the next frame so
therefore that was important to consider
a couple of frames rather than just just
one frame because the mem the uh a
network otherwise doesn't actually have
any memory so a different way to say
that is that actually the input here are
not the raw observations but there's
just a very simple handcrafted agent
update function which looks at the
observations which could be considered
raw frames and then stacks them and
processes them appropriately to give you
an agent state but there's still no
long-term memory
of course there's a need for an
expiration policy and indeed in dqm this
was literally taken to be epsilon greedy
with a small epsilon like 0.05 or 0.01
and there was a replay buffer
where you could store and sample past
transitions this replay buffer didn't
store all of the transitions instead it
stored like the last 1 million
transitions or something like that so at
the time when you go beyond 1 million
transitions then it would start throwing
them away
and in addition there's a subtle other
thing which was called a target network
and this was one of the innovations that
made dqn work more effectively
so we're going to define a new weight
vector that concludes all contains all
of the weights of a network of exactly
the same shape and size as the
neural network that defines our q value
and we're going to use that to bootstrap
so the weight update function is exactly
the same as the online q learning
algorithm that we saw on the previous
slide except for this one change
where there's a w minus here w minus is
just a name the minus doesn't mean it's
negative or anything it's just a name to
say oh this is a different weight vector
different from the one
that we're updating w
so then if we're not updating w minus
how does that one update well that one
is just updated by copying in
occasionally the online weight vectors
so what mean what this means is that
during learning you're basically
regressing on a different value function
for a while
while keeping it fixed for say 10 000
steps and then you copy in the online
weight so that occasionally it does get
better over time
this makes the learning target a little
bit more stable and it was helpful for
learning in the qn
this might sound a little bit similar
and familiar uh when we talked about
double learning for double q learning
this is not quite double q learning yet
because it is still using the same
parameters here to evaluate the action
and to pick the action it's just using
this w minus now maybe something for you
to think about oh how would you then
implement double learning in this
framework what would that look like
and then there was an optimizer applied
to actually minimize the loss in the
original dqm this was rms prop so this
update would be tossed into the rms prop
optimizer which also stores some
statistics of past gradients and then
would compute the actual updates by
taking all of that into account
current day people still use rms proper
adam typically
or variations of this
the replay and the target networks are
designed to make the reinforcement
learning look a little bit more like
supervised learning and the reasoning
behind that was essentially that if you
make it more look more like super first
device learning is more likely to work
because we already know that deep
learning works quite well for supervised
learning for or for regression and
classification for supervised data sets
the replay kind of scrambles the data so
that the sampling seems more ideal if
you then if you would uh
just give all of the samples
sequentially and the target network just
makes the regression target less
non-stationary on every single timestamp
and this might help the learning
dynamics
neither of those is strictly necessary
for for good learning but in the dqn
setup they did help performance and they
are still sometimes used in modern
algorithms as well and sometimes too
much effect
okay so that brings us basically to the
end of this lecture where
these last two things are kind of an
interesting intriguing like insight into
what makes deep reinforcement building
an interesting field so turning the
replay and the target networks
um making help making that make use of
that to make the reinforcement planning
look more like supervised learning
this was done of course because we're
combining the deep learning part in so
in some sense you could say this is deep
learning aware reinforcement learning so
we're changing the reinforcement during
update a little bit with these target
networks and we're using experience
replay deliberately here because this
makes better use of these deep networks
that we're using
the converse also exists there are also
things that could be called
reinforcement learning aware deep
learning where sometimes people change
for instance the network architecture or
the optimizer in certain ways to maybe
play better with the fact that we're
doing reinforcement learning
the fact that these exist that that
there are some important design
considerations that could be called deep
learning aware reinforcement wording or
reinforcement learning aware deep
learning
this is exactly what makes the
reinforcement learning a field of its
own in some sense the subfield of its
own with really interesting research
questions that are not pure
reinforcement pruning questions they're
not pure deep learning questions but
they're really on this intersection of
these two really exciting fields
okay that brings us to the end of this
lecture
as always please ask questions on moodle
if you have any and
in our live q a thanks for your
attention